GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME
BACK TO THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS
CALLED TO ORDER. A WE ARE
CONTINUING TO RELAX SOME OF OUR
CODE PROTOCOLS HOWEVER ALL
INDIVIDUALS IN THE HEARING ROOM
MUST WEAR A MASK. AND ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDING
A HEARING IN THE CAPITAL NEEDS
TO WEAR A MASK AT ALL TIMES
WHILE IN THE BUILDING. YOU CAN
TESTIFY IN PERSON IN THE
HEARING ROOM AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION ON THE
CAPITOL GROUNDS OR BY USING OUR
TELEPHONE SERVICE. THE NUMBER
TO CALL IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. FOR EACH BILL BEING
DISCUSSED TODAY THERE'LL BE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR TWO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION TO
PROVIDE TWO MINUTES EACH OF
COMMENTARY FOR TOTAL OF NO MORE
THAN FOUR MINUTES FOR THE-
OPPOSITION AND FOUR MINUTES FOR
THE PROPONENTS. FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES CALLING INTO THE
PHONE LINE YOU'RE GONNA BE
PLACE IN THE QUEUE. UNTIL YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. PLEASE MUTE OUR
DEVICE TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTIONS IF YOU'RE NOT
NEEDED AND THERE'S AN ECHO YOU
WILL BE DISCONNECTED. SUPPORTED
OPPOSITION WILL BE BLENDED ON
THE PHONE LINES. PLEASE BE
BRIEF AND THE ONLY COMMENTARY
WE WILL HEAR FROM PEOPLE ON THE
PHONE WHO ARE NOT A REGISTERED
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION IS YOUR
NAME. YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION THAT'S ALL. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE. TWENTY
NINETY THREE AND OUR STAFF WILL
TRY TO HELP. BECAUSE WE ONLY
TAKE YOUR NAME YOUR-
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
BY PHONE. I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
PROVIDE ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THAT YOU WANT TO SHARE WITH US.
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE THAT WILL BE RECEIVED.
FINALLY THE ASSEMBLY HAS
EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEE AND
FLOOR PROCEEDINGS IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS. CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
HEARING IS PROHIBITED. SUCH
CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE REMOVING A
MASK AND REFUSING TO PUT IT
BACK ON. TALKING OR MAKING LOUD.
NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE
UTTERING LOUD THREATENING OR
ABUSIVE LANGUAGE SPEAKING WATER
THAN THE TIME ALLOWED ALLOTTED
ASCENDED DISCUSSION OF MATTERS
NOT RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF
THE HEARING OR THE BILL AND
OTHER DESTRUCTIVE ACTS. TO
ADDRESS ANY DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT
I WILL TAKE THE FOLLOWING STEPS
IF IT INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR
HEARING PROCESS I WILL DIRECT
THEM TO STOP AND WARNED THEM
THAT CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS MAY
RESULT IN REMOVAL FROM THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. WE WILL ALSO
DOCUMENT ON THE RECORD THE
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED IN THE
NATURE OF DESTRUCTIVE CONDUCT I
MIGHT TEMPORARILY RECESSED THE
HEARING. IF THE CONDUCT
CONTINUES I WILL REQUEST THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE SERGEANTS AND
ESCORTING THE INDIVIDUAL FROM
THE CAPITOL BUILDING. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COOPERATION. TODAY WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF ITEMS TO
DISCUSS- WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN
OUR BILLS ALTHOUGH I DO NOT
BELIEVE WE HAVE A QUORUM
PRESENT SO WILL BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE OUR FIRST BILL UP
TODAY IS SENATE BILL. TO SET A
SIX SEVENTY FOUR BY DURAZO
SENATOR DRAWS SO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR HELP AND YOUR
GUIDANCE AND THE COMMITTEE AND
THE STAFF- BASED ON THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND CONVERSATIONS
ON GUIDANCE I'M ACCEPTING. ALL
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. LAST YEAR
THE GOVERNOR APPROVED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO REQUIRE THAT
ALL TRANSPORTATION IN THE STATE
BE POWERED BY CLEAN ENERGY IN A
FEW SHORT YEARS. SINCE THAT
TIME MANY HAVE CELEBRATED BUT A
LOT OF CALIFORNIA WORKERS ARE
WONDERING WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN TO THEIR JOBS IF THEY
WORK IN A POWER PLANT AND OIL
REFINERY YEAR. MANUFACTURING IF
THE NEW JOBS OR OVERSEAS OR IF
THEY PAY MINIMUM WAGES WITHOUT
BENEFITS. PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
GOVERNOR NEW SOME HAVE
COMMITTED THEMSELVES TO
CREATING GOOD JOBS BUT THE BIG
QUESTION IS HOW. HOW ARE GOOD
JOBS GOING TO BE CREATED WHEN
SOME COMPANIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
THEY WILL FIGHT TOOTH AND NAIL
TO PROVIDE EVEN THE MOST BASIC
GOOD JOB REQUIREMENTS. SB SIX
SEVENTY FOUR IS AN IMPORTANT
ANSWER TO THE QUESTION OF HOW
WE WILL GET TO OUR GOAL. THE
ENTIRE LABOR AND ENVIRONMENTAL
MOVEMENTS ARE IN AGREEMENT THAT
SIX SEVENTY SB SIX SEVENTY FOUR
IS A CRUCIAL FIRST STEP FOR
GETTING TO GOOD GREEN JOBS. SB
SIX SEVENTY FOUR WILL SUPPORT
EQUITABLE HIGH QUALITY
TRANSPORTATION AND RELATED
MANUFACTURING JOBS IN OUR STATE
AND COUNTRY AND WILL ENSURE
THAT THE BENEFITS OF THE
TRANSITION TO CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INCLUDE. GOOD
WAGES QUALITY JOBS AND
ESPECIALLY FOR CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY LEFT OUT. THIS
BILL FOCUSES ON CREATING
QUALITY CLIMATE RESILIENT JOBS
WITH OUR TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS
LAST YEAR'S AB THREE NINETY
EIGHT REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE. OF PUTTING GOOD
FOR THE CALIFORNIA THE HIGH
ROAD OF GOODS AND OUR JOBS AND
CLIMATE ACTION PLAN FOR TWENTY
THIRTY. IDENTIFIES GOODS
MOVEMENT AND MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE
AS THE BIGGEST SINGLE
CONTRIBUTOR OF POLLUTION. I
ALSO SAID AT THE SAME TIME THE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM UNDERPINS
OUR ECONOMY. THE FREE SYSTEM
MOVES TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
GOODS EACH YEAR SUPPORTING
NEARLY ONE THIRD OF THE STATE
ECONOMY AND MORE THAN FIVE
MILLION JOBS. THAT IS WHY
PARTNERSHIPS WITH BUSINESS CAN
LEAD TO PROSPERITY FOR
EVERYONE. THE CALIFORNIA JOBS
PLAN AND US JOBS PLAN OR
COMPONENT OF AN APPLICATION
SUBMITTED BY APPLICANTS FOR
COVERED PUBLIC CONTRACT A
CONTRACT. THAT SPECIFIES THE
MINIMUM NUMBER OF JOBS PROPOSED
WAGES BENEFITS INVESTMENT IN
TRAINING AND TARGETED HIRING UP
PLANS. THE CALIFORNIA LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
WILL WORK WITH RELEVANT PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO DESIGN THE CRITERIA
THAT WILL BE USED FOR SCORING
THESE ELEMENTS. THE JOBS PLAN
COMPONENT WILL NOT REQUIRE ANY
NEW MINIMUM COMMITMENTS OTHER
THAN THOSE ALREADY REQUIRED BY
RELEVANT FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL LAWS. THE PROCEDURES IN
SYRIA WILL AWARD ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERATION TO APPLICANTS.
BUT WILL NOT BE WAITED HIGHER
THAN 15% OF THE OVERALL SCORE-
SCORE. WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
MEET THE GOALS OF OUR OWN
CALIFORNIA FUTURE WORK
COMMISSION MADE UP OF
BUSINESSES COMMUNITY AND LABOR
TO CREATE INCLUSIVE LONG TERM
ECONOMIC GROWTH. WE NEED CLEAR
COMMITMENTS TO QUALITY JOB
CREATION AND PUBLIC ACCESS TO
INFORMATION RELATED TO THE
PROMISES MADE IN OUR CONTRACTS
WE WILL MOVE TRANSPORTATION
FUNDS TO SUPPORT THE CREATION
OF THESE GOOD JOBS. AND ENSURE
PROACTIVE EFFORTS TO GIVE
ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITIES TO
THOSE WHO NEED THE JOBS TODAY
WE HAVE MELANIE TO MILA PRASAD
FROM JOBS TO MOVE AMERICA- AS A
WITNESS TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE YOUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT UP NEXT I BELIEVE BY
PHONE. K. OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES
FOR- ROXANA THE COMMONALITY AND-
SORRY THAT'S THE WRONG BILL-
MELANIE WHO ARE YOUR WITESSES
ARE YOU'RE LOOKING FOR MELANIE
JIM MILLER PRASAD. OKAY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MAY FIFTEENTH.
YES YOUR TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MELANIE
PRESS FIVE ALL AROUND THE
CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR WAS
MARATHON AND NATIONAL STRATEGIC
REFLECTION QUALITY FROM
MEDICAID AND TO INSURANCE THAT
PUBLIC FOLLOWING OUR FRIENDS IN
A WAY THAT MAXIMIZES THE PUBLIC.
I'M HERE TO VOIGTS SUPPORT AT
THE FUNDS. THAT JOB AND- AT
THAT'S WHY IT'S HOME OF THE
METHOD YEP ALMOST. HOPEFULLY
COMPLAIN THAT. THAT WITH
SPECIAL LEVEL INTER THOUSAND
ELEVEN BY LAST ANGELES
METROPOLITAN TRANSIT AUTHORITY.
I THANK YOU FOR AGENCIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY INCLUDING ON MAC
THIRTY CHICAGO ATLANTA BOSTON
AND MANY ST PAUL DEGREE FIVE OF
JOBS FOR LOCAL. IT WOULD ALSO
INCLUDE IN THE SHOW BASS OF
LOCAL HIGH LOCAL ACT AND IF
YOU'RE HIGH. MISTER FRANK RAIL
ACT. THE QUALITY WORK AND TO
CREATE HIGH PAYING LONG TERM
MEDICAL CAREER FROM CLEANING.
LEFT THOUGHT BEEN I. TO HIGH.
WHEN YEAH ARE. THAT FELT OUT
SHE THE MARC BERMAN THE THING
THAT WOULD WORK COMPANY COULD
PASS WHICH BANKS AND- WITH THE
PLAN THAT WILL WORK HI ROAD
AFTER. BECAUSE STRONG MIDDLE
CLASS THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE SOME.
XTIME PRODUCT. INVESTMENTS THE
FUND HELLO DILUTES. TODAY I
THINK WITH OVER TWO. MY AND
EVEN ON THE STREET ORGANISED.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M GONNA PAUSE THE HEARING
FROM GOING TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. THE SEGMENT SECRETARY
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FRIEDMAN HERE FRIEDMAN FONG.
BERMAN CUNNINGHAM. DALY DAVIES.
GIPSON KALRA. WE MEDINA. THIS
AREA. WHEN BLOOM. WARD WICKS.
WE HAVE A QUORUM. RIVAS. WE
HAVE CORN THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WE HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS A
SPEAKING MICHAEL PENN AND THE
PIMENTAL FROM THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION OPERATOR IF
YOU CAN PLEASE FIND. FIND HIM.
AARON AND THEN THERE. GO AHEAD
PLEASE MANAGER NUMBER THEM WITH
YOU NOW- MICHAEL PIMENTEL WITH
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING EIGHTY FIVE
TRANSIT AND RAIL AGENCIES
ACROSS THE STATE I'LL START MY
TESTIMONY BY THINKING THAT
SENATOR AND- STOP AT THE TIME
THEY SPEND WITH US TO DISCUSS
THE BILL IN ITS PROPOSED
AMENDMENT. OF THE BILL AS IT
WILL SOON BE AMENDED I
CERTAINLY MUCH IMPROVED- BUT
THAT SENATE NOT WITHSTANDING
I'M HERE TO VOTE SEVERAL
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL I DON'T
TO BE CLEAR WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON IT AT THIS TIME.
THE BILL ISSUE YOU HEARD
REQUIRES TRANSIT AGENCIES
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERATION TO CONTRACTORS IN
A COMPETITIVE PROCUREMENT THAT
PROMISED PROGRESS ON VARIOUS
JOB METRICS- THESE PROVISIONS
WILL CERTAINLY WELL INTENDED
REPRESENT A SIGNIFICANT AND
THEN TESTED GOING UP THE
PROCUREMENT POLICY THAT HAD TO
DATE ONLY BEEN TRIAL BY SEVERAL
PUBLIC AGENCIES WITH MUCH
NARROWER PARAMETERS AND TO BE
SPECIFIC IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
U. S. EMPLOYMENT PLAN U. S. B.
P. THE MODEL FOR THIS
LEGISLATION HAS ONLY. BEEN
APPLIED TO BE A PROCUREMENT.
CONGRESS DISCUSSES FORMALIZING
YOU. THEY'VE ALSO CHOSEN TO
KEEP AT THE- ON. PARKED HERE.
BOB I CAN. THIS BILL TO
CONTRACT. TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE. WHICH IS
DEFINED ONLY BY SHORTLISTED
EXCLUSION. BECAUSE SUCH POLICY
IS UNTESTED. WE DON'T KNOW-STATE MIGHT IMPACT THE SIDE
THAT BEAT GOALS CREATE NEW
CHALLENGES FOR MEDIUM AND SMALL
STATE AGENCY. THAT NEW GROUNDS
FOR PETROL TESTER LITIGATION OR
DRIVE UP PROJECT COSTS. THESE
ARE POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT THE TRANSIT AGENCY THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MUST EXAMINE
AND THAT MAY NOT BE
COUNTERACTED BY THE CREATION
JOBS. WELCOME TO THE BILL
IMPACTS STREAMLINED PROCUREMENT
POLICY- THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SPECIFICALLY AUTHORIZED.
IMPACTING THE BILL THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN AFFECT CONVERT
THESE PROCUREMENT POLICIES. THE
BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT. THAT
WOULD HAPPEN WITHOUT DISCUSSION
ON THAT POTENTIALLY SEISMIC
CHANGE TO PROCUREMENT LAW.
FINALLY THE BILL WAITING TO
CONGRESS TO DEMAND BY
EXPLICITLY CREATING NEW
REQUIREMENTS. FOR PROCUREMENT
FUNDED BY FEDERAL FUNDS. THAT
WE UNDERSTAND THE BILL DOES
INCLUDE A VARIETY STATE COURTS
TO ENSURE CONFORMITY WITH
FEDERAL LAW. BUT IT COULD STILL
LEAD TO UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. AND BECAUSE OF
THAT. AT THE BILL COULD
ACTUALLY IN SOME CASES SHIFT
JOB AWAY FROM CALIFORNIA. IT
MANUFACTURES AND OTHER STATES
IMPOSE STRONGER U. S. JOHNSON
WHICH FIGURES THAT ARE IN STATE
MANUFACTURERS. I'M WITH THAT WE
DO APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AGAIN
BE COLLABORATION WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE. I
WILL JUST BE ASKING FOR
MEASURED APPROACH- AS WE LOOK.
TO EXPAND THIS CALL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVE NO
OTHER WAY REGISTERED WITNESSES
WERE NOW GOING TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY. I DO
NOT SEE ANYONE IS THERE ANYONE
AT THE REMOTE LOCATION. NO OKAY
FROM. US LET'S OPEN THE
TELEPHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES
FOR AND AGAINST SB SIX SEVENTY
FOUR AND JUST TO REMIND THE
PUBLIC. NAME ORGANIZATION IN
YOUR POSITION ONLY NO TESTIMONY
WILL BE TAKEN AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THEY'VE BEEN DONE IF YOU
DO WISH TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR FIRST
WILL COME FROM THE LINE FORTY
LINE FORTY GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES YOU I LET ME IN
FOR MOVE LA. AND WE'RE CALLING
IN SUPPORT- THE SENATE BILL SIX
SEVENTY FOUR. THANK YOU. NEXT
OVER THE LINE FORTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
PERSECUTOR FROM BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND SUPPORT AT
EIGHT SIX SEVEN FOUR THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE THE SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
PARDON ME LINE SIXTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MEDICARE MEMBERS MIKE MONEY
GOING TO BE AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE HI
PRINCE COUNSEL. IN THE WESTERN
STATE COUNCIL PEOPLE WORKERS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT OVER
THE LINE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN HE WON.
I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING OUT OF
THEIR WORKERS DISTRICT TWELVE
AND THE POINT OF IT THE SIX
SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU. NEXT
OVER THE LINE EIGHTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD EIGHTEEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS THE WALL
COMING UP THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION CORNER TRANSIT WE
ALSO ARE BRIMMING TO DRAW THE
BILL BUT WE DO SHARE THE
CONCERNS OF THE CALPERS TRIMS
ASSOCIATION BUT MICHAEL THANK
YOU AUTHORED THE SOUTH. IN THE
COMMITTEE- FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THE QUESTION TO CONCERNS
WITHOUT THANK YOU. NEXT OVER
THE LINE. FORTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MICHELLE
CANNELLA TO LOS ANGELES
CLEANTECH INCUBATOR IMPORT
EXACTLY SIX GOING TO THE PARK
THANK YOU. NEXT OVER THE LINE.
FIFTY FIVE. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON I NEED A AT THE NEEDS
THAT ARE GOING WELL WITH THE
WAREHOUSE WORKER RESEARCH
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT AS
BEACH. SIX SEVEN FOUR. THE NEXT
OVER THE LINE. THIRTY THREE.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE IN
SUPPORT. AND AS A REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TOM CAN'T
BE ON BEHALF OF YOUR W. REGION
EIGHT IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOT TAKEN OUT TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANYONE HAS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. C.
SHAKING HEADS. BLANK FACES A-
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WELL I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BEING A TRAILBLAZER
IN THIS AREA AND FOR MAKING
SURE THAT AS CALIFORNIA SPENDS
ITS PUBLIC TAX DOLLARS IT DOES
SO IN A WAY THAT ALSO LIFTS ALL
BOATS AND HELP SUPPORT GOOD
JOBS AND WAGES RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR WORKING WITH US AND TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OF THE TRANSIT
AGENCIES I KNOW THAT YOU'LL
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS.
WORKABLE AND DOABLE AND ACHIEVE
YOUR GOALS BUT ALSO GIVES THEM
THE FLEXIBILITY THAT THEY NEED
AND OUT OF MY OFFICE WILL ALSO
CONTINUE TO BE THERE IS A
RESOURCE CENTER MAKES AND TO
KEEP AN EYE ON THIS BILLS MOVE
THROUGH THE PROCESS BUT VERY
IMPORTANT- BILL AND- CERTAINLY
AND AN AUTHOR WHO IS- COMMITTED
TO THESE ISSUES- WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FOR ALL YOUR SUPPORT AND
GUIDANCE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CAN WE
HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN. HI
FRIEDMAN HI FONG. SORRY SAY
IT'S- ANOTHER NUMBER. FONG NOT
VOTING BERMAN. BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM. DALY DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES NOW GIPSON.
GIPSON I KALRA. CLUB. I'M SORRY
ABOUT THAT KALRA KILEY. LEE I
MEDINA. MEDINA I NAZARIAN WHEN.
WHEN NO RIVAS. WARD. WARD I
WICKS WICKS I. THE VOTING IS
NINE TO NINETY TWO THE BILL IS
OUT WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND THEN
WE HAVE- SB SEVEN SIXTY TWO BY
COMES ALL IS UP NEXT. DO WE
HAVE ANY AUTHORS PRESENT.
ANYONE HERE WITH THE BILL UP
HERE. ANY OF MY MEMBERS HAVE
BILLS NOPE OKAY ANY AUTHOR
WITHIN EAR SHOT ANYONE WHO GETS
HERE FIRST. WE WILL TAKE YOUR
BILL UP YOU'LL GET EXTRA CREDIT
POINTS. YEAH. YES LET'S DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE SUGGESTION WE DO
HAVE ONE BILL WE'VE REMOVED THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SB SIX TWENTY
NINE CAN WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE REST OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. OKAY THE MOTIONS
SECONDLY ROLL CALL PLEASE.
CONSENT ITEMS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN HI FONG FONG HI BERMAN
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM. DALY DALY
AYE DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON
GIPSON I KALRA KALRA I LEE.
THREE I MEDINA MEDINA I
NAZARIAN. WHEN. TWENTY I WHEN I
RIVAS WARD. WARD I WICKS WICKS
I. TWELVE I'M SORRY TWELVE
MONTHS OKAY TWELVE VOTES THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED I
SEE GENERAL ROTH. IS HERE. FOR
SB SIX TWENTY NINE YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY SIR THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS BILL SB
SIX TWENTY NINE EXPANDS
PATHWAYS FOR INMATES TO TAKE
PART IN CDC OURS CAL ID PROGRAM
NEARLY EVERY INDIVIDUAL
RELEASED FROM STATE PRISON
FACES SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
pSUCCESSFUL REENTRY AND THE LACK
OF A VALID CALIFORNIA ID OR
DRIVER'S LICENSE CAN CERTAINLY
EXACERBATE THESE BARRIERS. FROM
SEEKING MEDICAL CARE IN
RECEIVING HOUSING ASSISTANCE TO
APPLYING FOR JOBS AND OPENING A
BANK ACCOUNT WITHOUT A VALID ID
NEWLY RELEASED INDIVIDUALS ARE
LOCKED OUT OF CRUCIAL SERVICES
AND OPPORTUNITIES TO SUCCEED.
RUBIO. WELL SINCE YOU'RE
CURRENTLY PROVIDES A PATHWAY
FOR INMATES TO OBTAIN CAL ID'S
AS THEY APPROACH THE RELEASE OF
REQUIREMENTS THAT YOU HAS
PRECLUDED. THOUSANDS OF THOSE
WHO WERE OTHERWISE READY
INELIGIBLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS KELADI PROGRAM. THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY WHAT THIS BILL DOES
AND AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
ADAM. SURE I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
AS FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO HAVE ANY WITNESSES
WITH YOU HERE TODAY. I HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM- CCIR BUT
SIMPLY TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS MR KEVIN HOFFMAN
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF PROGRAM
OPERATIONS AT CDC ARE THE
VISION OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS WE'LL SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS WILL GO TO THE
WITNESS OTHERWISE IN LIEU OF
THAT IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
THE TEST IN THE- HEARING ROOM
TO TESTIFY. ON SB SIX TWENTY
NINE SEEING NONE ANYONE IN THE
REMOTE LOCATION I'M GONNA SAY
NO OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE PHONE LINES THIS IS FOR
ANYONE WHO IS TESTIFYING FOR OR
AGAINST SB. SIX TWENTY NINE.
OKAY ONCE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN. ZERO SB SIX TWENTY
NINE PER OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT.
ONE ZERO OUR FIRST WILL COME
FROM THE LINE SIXTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
CRYSTAL SHE DOES ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTER FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU TOM
WYMAN I'M WITH. HOMEWORK SAN
DIEGO PROGRAM THAT ASSISTS
ETCETERA SO THE SYSTEM PROGRAM
THAT WORKS WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES CALLING AT THE PORT. AND
THE LAST ONE WE HAVE IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME IS ONE SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. UNDER
WATER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX TO NINE THANK YOU.
WAS THAT OUR LAST OUR LAST
WITNESS. IT PARDON ME WE HAVE
NO MORE IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WITHOUT WILL GO TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANYONE HAS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MISTER GIBSON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MADAM CHAIR I WANT TO ASK
THE AUTHOR IF HE WOULD BE
INCLINED TO ADD ME ON AS A CO
AUTHOR JOINT AUTHORS- THERE'S
SOME WORK THAT I'VE DONE. SINCE
I'VE BEEN THE LEGISLATURE NOT
ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE IT'S IN THE
POLICY IS GOING TO RIGHT
DIRECTION AND ALSO. IT SPEAKS
TO US DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO TRY TO HELP THOSE WHO PAID
THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY- REMOVE A
BEAR SO I'M ENTHUSIASTIC. ABOUT
THE BILL AND THAT'S REASON WHY
MOVE THE BILL AND WILL LOVE TO
OFFER TO CONSIDER ME AS A CO
AUTHOR JOINT AUTHORS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH RESPECT BASS MY
VOTE. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
THE COMMITTEE- MISTER MEDINA.
WHEN I THANK THE SENATOR FROM
RIVERSIDE- FOR INTRODUCING THE
BILL AND I'D LIKE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES- WOULD LIKE TO
BE CONSIDERED AS A CO AUTHOR
VERY MUCH UNDERSTANDING HOW
IMPORTANT ID'S ARE- WHEN YOU'RE
COMING OUT OF A- INCARCERATIONS.
ANYONE ELSE ONE THING THAT I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND I KNOW THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE MP TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS IS A FEASIBLE
PROGRAM FOR THEM TO IMPLEMENT
BUT CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT IS
NECESSARY TO HELP PEOPLE FIND
THEIR WAY BACK INTO SOCIETY-
AND- BECOME MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. SO THANK YOU WITH
THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
YOU KNOW MEMBERS OF THIS
ASSEMBLY HAVE BEEN CHAMPIONS OF
THIS ISSUE FOR YEARS. AND I'M
CERTAINLY HONORED TO HAVE THE
SUPPORT. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WITH THAT CAN WE HAVE A
ROLL CALL PLEASE. THE MOTION IS
THE PAST TO APPROPRIATIONS
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I FONG.
FONG I BERMAN BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM. DALY DALY AYE
DAVIES. DAVIES I GIPSON GIPSON
I KALRA KALRA I LI LI I MEDINA
MEDINA I NAZARIAN. WHEN. WHEN
NO RIVAS. WARD WICKS. ONE OF
WAS THAT I THINK THANK YOU LORD
I WICKS WICKS I. ELEVEN ONE
ELEVEN ONE THE BILLS OUT WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MANAGER THANK
YOU AND I SEE SENATOR GONZALEZ
HERE. YOU MAY PROCEED ONE READY
MA'AM. THANK YOU GOOD I WILL
NOT GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SP SEVEN TWO SIX
WHICH MAKES THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM MORE
EQUITY FOCUSED. AND WILL
REQUIRE A COLLABORATIVE
INTERAGENCY PLANNING TO
OFFICIALLY PROMOTE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FRAUD
CALIFORNIANS. THIS ADVANCES
EQUITY BY SPECIFYING THAT AT
LEAST 50% OF CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM DOLLARS.
BENEFIT INDIVIDUALS LIVING IN
DISADVANTAGED IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES FIRST. REQUIRING
DIRECT INVESTMENTS IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. THESE BENEFITS
INCLUDE INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
TO HELP GET THE WORST POLLUTING
DIESEL POWERED MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES OFF THE ROAD. AND
PROJECTS THAT MAKE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION MORE ACCESSIBLE
FOR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. SB
SEVENTY SIX ALSO PLANS FOR THE
FUTURE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION BY
CREATING A SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION STRATEGY. WHICH
WILL CRACK REQUIRE MULTIPLE
AGENCIES TO IDENTIFY DEVELOP
STRATEGIES TO ACHIEVE EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS GOALS. ASSISTING ALL
TRANSPORTATION STRATEGY WILL
TAKE A BROAD LOOK AT OUR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS
EVALUATING THE ROLE OF NEAR
ZERO EMISSIONS THE REDUCTION
TRANSIT AND ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION. ALONGSIDE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES REDUCING NOT
ONLY GHGS BUT AIR POLLUTANTS.
LASTLY I DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THE BOTH THE MODERNIZATION OF
THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM AND SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION STRATEGY ARE
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THE DISPROPORTIONATE
BURDEN OF GHG EMISSIONS AND AIR
POLLUTANTS. IN OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES MANY OF
WHICH I REPRESENT I RECOGNIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING A
DIVERSE PORTFOLIO OF TECHNOLOGY
OPTIONS TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
TODAY I HAVE READ ADDIS WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ENERGY
CONSULTING. AND MYLES MILLER
ATTORNEY FOR NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I BELIEVE MR ODYSSEUS HERE
IN PERSON WELCOME. JUST TALK
IT'LL IT'LL GO THROUGH TO GET
ON FOR YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS READ OUT US ON
BEHALF OF CAL START THE STRONG
SUPPORT TODAY AS A SPONSOR OF
THE MEASURE. INSTEAD OF
FOCUSING ON THE MERITS OF THE
BILL I THINK I'LL SPEND MY TIME
TALKING ABOUT SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION THAT YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD FROM OUR MAY BE HEARING
FROM HERE MOMENTARILY. WE'D
LIKE TO ARGUE THAT SOME OF THAT
OPPOSITION IS ACTUALLY SHOWING
THAT THEY SUPPORT THE PROGRAM
IT IT'S A CRITICAL PROGRAM TO
OUR STATE AND HELPING US SCALE
UP RB AT VARIOUS IN VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGIES. HOWEVER THEY'RE
BRINGING BAGGAGE TO THIS
CONVERSATION LIKE WE ALL DO
BASED ON THE BEHAVIOR OF THE
PAST ACTIVITIES OR RECENTLY F
THE AGENCY. AND WE THINK IT'S
FAIR THAT OBVIOUSLY THEY WOULD
ENTER THIS CONVERSATION
THINKING ABOUT THE WAY IN WHICH
THE ENERGY COMMISSION HAS BEEN
WORKING ON THE PROGRAM SO FAR.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THEY'VE GONE
TOO FAR IN THEIR ASK THAT THE
EXTREME CLARITY THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR IN THIS LEGISLATION IS AN
APPROPRIATE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO PUSH FOR ANNABEL. AND
EXTREME CLARITY LEAST IN OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS TRYING TO GET
DOLLAR AMOUNTS OR PERCENTAGES
INTO THE BILL. THERE'S THREE
CRITICAL REASONS WE WOULD ARGUE
THAT THAT'S A PROBLEM. ONE IT
OPENS UP THE DOOR FOR ANY OTHER
TECHNOLOGY TO TRY TO COME IN
AND GET ITS CARVE OUT ITS
SPECIAL PIECE OR ITS PERCENTAGE.
TO ENFORCE IS THE LEGISLATURE
TO PRIDE TRY TO PICK WINNERS. I
WILL REMIND YOU WHEN THIS
PROGRAM WAS ORIGINALLY
AUTHORIZED EVERYBODY THOUGHT
EVERY SINGLE DOLLARS SHOULD BE
SPENT. ON CELLULOSIC ETHANOL
AND THAT WASN'T THE CASE. AND
IT WAS GOOD THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DID NOT PICK A
WINNER. THIRD I THINK PEOPLE
HAVE NOT ACTUALLY READ THE BILL
OF WHAT SENATOR GONZALEZ HAS
BEEN PUSHING AT THE C. P. P.
PROGRAM. THE CIVIC FOR IF YOU
LOOK AT PAGE TEN AND ELEVEN
IT'S VERY CLEARLY LAYING OUT
THAT HYDROGEN IS A KEY CRITICAL
AND FOCAL POINT OF THIS PROGRAM
GOING FORWARD. AS WELL AS LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE.
FOR THOSE REASONS WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE
MILES MUELLER FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL ON
THE PHONE OPERATOR IF YOU CAN
PLEASE FIND- ME FIND. THEM.
GOOD AFTERNOON GENEROUSLY IN.
GO AHEAD. GREAT MY MOTHER HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND
ALSO TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF
OUR PARTNERS IN THE CHARGE
AHEAD CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN- THE
GOAL IS TO THE CLEAN AIR
COMMUNITIES FOR A BETTER
ENVIRONENT ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA AND THE GREEN
RUNNING INTO TO ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION.
THIS BILL WOULD MODERNIZE THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
GREEN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM TO
INCORPORATE THE LATEST STATE
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS AND REMOTE
TECHNOLOGY MUTUAL INVESTMENT IN
PROJECTS THAT WOULD REDUCE
HARMFUL CRITERIA AIR POLLUTANTS
IN AIR TOXICS EMISSIONS
OVERBURDENED COMMUNITIES ARE WE
SPECIALLY APPRECIATE THE STRONG
EQUITY COMPONENT OF THE BILL
THAT WOULD ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDING I WILL BENEFIT ARE
DISADVANTAGED IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. THINGS LIKE
REPLACING POLLUTING DIESEL
VEHICLES WITH ZERO EMISSIONS
VEHICLE AND A PLAIN PUBLICLY
ACCEPTABLE REFUELING OR
CHARGING STATION SERVING LONGER
DOCUMENT BECAUSE ALL
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE TO HAVE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION AND CLEAN
OUT THE WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY HERE
TODAY AND RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I HAVE TO LISTEN.
IN OPPOSITION. FIRST LET'S GO
TO MARGOT PARKES FROM WITH
SPOKE ON THE PHONE OPERATOR IF
YOU CAN PLEASE FIND MISS PARKS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MARKUP HERE
IS THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION. I AM HERE TODAY
UNFORTUNATELY IN THE POLLS AND
THAT AMENDED POSITION ON. SEVEN
TWENTY SIX. WELL WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
ATTENTION REQUIRE CRACK
AGENCIES TRANSPORTATION
COORDINATION AND PLANNING ON
THE PHONE. NUMBER OF THE POLICY
IS UNFORTUNATELY OUTLINED THE
BILL ARE DEEPLY CONNECTED
PARTIALLY DEAF AND I THOUGHT
THE GOAL OF ACHIEVING.
IMMEDIATE AIR QUALITY BENEFITS
WHICH RECENTLY SUPPORT AUTHOR
AND- THE BILL ALLOWS AIR
RESOURCES BOARD BOB COULTER
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR EMISSIONS
REDUCTION. OUTLINED IN THE
NASDAQ THE COMMUNITY NATURE HAS
ACTUALLY ALREADY BEEN COMPLETED
BY THE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY.
SECONDLY THAT THAT HAPPENED
TRADE PROGRAM AND LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD REQUIRE EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS AND FUEL
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. AND
ADDITIONAL WALL COULD HAVE A
HARMFUL EFFECT OF INCREASING
PRICES TO CONSUMERS WITHOUT-
DELIVERING ANY REAL BENEFIT. I
WATER RECENTLY FOUND IN THE
TRANSPORTATION POLICIES HAVE
UNCLEAR METRIC THAT. SHOULD BE
DOUBLE THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE THE PROGRAMS ARE WORKING
THE FOR DIRECTING AGENCIES.
ABDUCTION BALL. SECONDLY
UNFORTUNATELY THE FIGHT AND
THINK THAT ROLE- AND HANDS AND
MODIFICATIONS OF THE BILL WELL
BELIEVE THE BALL. OF WAX IN IT
CLEARLY ABOUT TECHNOLOGICALLY-
MUTUAL ADVANCEMENT THE
TRANSPORTATION. OF MONEY NOW
THERE ARE MANY TECHNOLOGY TODAY
THAT ARE AVAILABLE THAT CAN
PROVIDE AIR QUALITY BENEFITS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE BILL DIRECTS
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD TO
DEVELOP A PLAN TO MEET THE
GOVERNOR'S GOAL OF ELIMINATING
THE SALE OF NEW LIGHT DUTY.
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINE. BUT THEY'LL
CAN'T POSSIBLY BE TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL IN SUPPORT OF AIR
QUALITY GOALS OUTLINED BY THE
AUTHOR WITH THAT TYPE OF
INCLUSION. AGAIN WE TOTALLY
AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR THAT A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN THAT TARGETS
NEAR AND LONG TERM AIR QUALITY.
IS IMPORTANT BUT UNFORTUNATELY
THE BILL.
IS THE TOP SLOT IN AT
THE PRO. THE ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE UNFORTUNATELY WE BELIEVE
SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX SHOULD
INCLUDE DEDICATED AND
PREDICTABLE FUNDING FOR LIGHT
DUTIES THAT INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
APPROPRIATE EXPENDITURE
CONSIDERING THE FUNDING FOR
THIS PROGRAM COMES FROM FEES
PAID BY LIGHT DUTY VEHICLE
OWNERS IN THE STATE. BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AUTOMAKERS WILL
HAVE INVESTED OVER TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS IN
THE INDUSTRY FUNDS FOR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. AND VEHICLE
ELECTRIFICATION CURRENTLY WE
OFFER FIFTY THREE DIFFERENT
MODELS TO CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
AND THAT NUMBER WILL GROW TO
OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MODELS
IN THE NEXT THREE YEARS. TO
MEET THE GOALS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER OF A
100% LIGHT DUTIES AT SALES BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE AIR B. AS
PROPOSED REGULATIONS THAT
REQUIRE. 86% OF NEW VEHICLE
SALES BEES AS BY TWENTY TWENTY
SIX TO MEET THIS REQUIREMENT
CURRENT THAT SALES MISS TRIPLE
IN THE NEXT FIVE YEARS.
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS WILL NOT
BY IS THAT IF THEY CAN'T REFUEL
THEM INDEED WERE ALREADY LOSING
GROUND BECAUSE OF OUR LACK OF
THE FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE STATE. RESEARCHERS AT UC
DAVIS RECENTLY REPORTED THAT
20% OF PREVIOUS THAT PURCHASERS
SWITCH BACK. TO INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINE VEHICLES
BECAUSE OF THE INCONVENIENCE OF
CHARGING. AND AS THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THE STATE
AND FAILED TO MEET ITS CURRENT
GOALS FOR ELECTRIC AND HYDROGEN
LIGHT DUTY REFUELLING
INFRASTRUCTURE. AT A TIME
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE INVESTING
MORE IS PROPOSING TO DO LAST
AND IS DOING SO ON THE BACKS OF
LIGHT DUTY VEHICLE OWNERS BY
REQUIRING THEIR FEES TO
SUBSIDIZE MEDIUM. AND HEAVY
DUTY THAT INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS
MARKET NEED CERTAINTY
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS NEED
CERTAINTY. AND WHAT MR ADDIS
CALLED BAGGAGE ALL COLFAX
CURRENTLY THE ENERGY COMMISSION
IS PROPOSING ZERO DOLLARS FOR
LIGHT DUTY INTERMISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. AND UNFORTUNATELY WORDS
IN THE BILL LIKE INCREASING
DON'T INSPIRE CONFIDENCE. IT'S
FOR THIS REASON THAT WE BELIEVE
SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX SHOULD BE
AMENDED TO REQUIRE THAT. UNTIL
THE STATE'S GOALS ARE MET AT
LEAST 50% OF THE FUNDS IN THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
THE ALLOCATED THE LIGHT DUTIES
EVERY FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE TO
YOUR RESUME YOU COULD. I WAS
JUST GOING TO CONCLUDE FOR
THESE REASONS WERE OPPOSING
LESS AMENDED AT THANK YOU AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE. ANYONE IN THE REMOTE
TO SPEAK I SEE ONE PLEASE COME
UP TO MY- THANK YOU JERRY GOOD
MOVE. I'D THREE COOK BEHALF OF
THE CAL. HIGH TO COAL. AND- ON
FOR. WITHIN A- UNLESS AMENDED.
TODAY FROM. THAT AS WORLD. TO I
THINK THAT. THANK I ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM. OKAY ANYBODY AT THE
REMOTE TEST. ANDERSON KEEPS
SAYING NO UNTIL. TELLS ME
OTHERWISE- AND THEN LET'S OPEN
UP THE PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN TWENTY
SIX. BUT AS A REMINDER IT IS
ONE ZERO. OUR FIRST WILL COME
FROM THE LINE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM SHARE THE CITY ENGINEER
THAT'S WITH THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA. ON BEHALF OF OUR
NEARLY HALF MILLION MEMBERS
INCLUDING NEARLY SEVENTY
THOUSAND REGISTERED TO THE
PARTICIPANTS WE STAND. TO
ASKING FOR THE TWENTY SIX. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR THIS IS BILL MURPHY
WITH ELDERS CLIMATE ACTION STAR
CAL IN SOCAL CHAPTERS AND THREE
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE. SEVENTY
SIX. MEMBERS SO THEY STOP ON
THE PATH THAT. AND BEFORE DOT
COM AND ON THE ASSEMBLY. THE
BOSTON. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE FORTY FOUR. TOM LET THEM
SET THE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION CURRENT WEAPON
THIRD WEAPON THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND UNION CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION FOR CLARITY REDUCE.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES ANGELINE'S
ALSO SMART SHEET METAL WORKERS
LOCAL ONE ZERO FIVE STANDING
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON MANAGER RESPONSIBLE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
COUNCIL OF LABORERS AND WE
STAND IN OPPOSITION ABOUT THE
CURRENT TWENTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR GOING. TO ONE THIRTY
TWO. HELLO IBM MILE WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ENERGY
CONSULTING REPORTING SUPPORT
FOR THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION EIGHTY P. AVC
COMPANIES EVERY POWER AND I'M
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK ANALYST
VALLEY TRANSIT AUTHORITY
ARRIVAL BALLARD POWER SYSTEMS.
CHANGE ENERGY HE NOW GREENPOWER
MOTOR COMPANY JB POINDEXTER AND
CO MOMENTUM DYNAMICS
CORPORATION MOTIV POWER SYSTEMS
NICOLETTE CORPORATION- NINE
SYSTEM PHOENIX MOTORCARS
PROTERRA ELECTRIC SUNLINE
TRANSIT AGENCY THE LION
ELECTRIC CO. BALOCH THE EIGHT
ENERGY. AND VOLVO GROUP NORTH
AMERICA THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE SEVENTY EIGHT.
I'M SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE NOW GO TO LINE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO HONORABLE CARE
VICE CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHRIS CANNON WITH THE
LOS ANGELES ORANGE COUNTY'S
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES. IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN TWENTY
SIX THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING
TO LINE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTER GAINES OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL NUMBER TWELVE
STANDING WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
TO SB. SEVEN TWENTY SIX. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MARGARET LATCHING ON
BEHALF OF CREWS WHO HAVE LESS
IMPORTANT IN INDICATION IF BAD
CHAD RIGHT HEARING IS ADDED TO
THE BILL THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE EIGHTY THIS GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CATHERINE DODD WITH THE
ALLIANCE OF NURSES FOR HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENTS WE SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NUMBER ONE THE WINE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHOWING THIS IS ROB
MILLER WITH THE L. A. LARGE
COUNTY BUILDING TRADES ON
BEHALF OF A HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND. WORKING MEN AND WOMEN
ACROSS FORTY EIGHT LOCAL UNIONS
WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. THANK YOU. CAN
ARE FILING QUEUE IS ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS RODNEY
COBLE'S WITH THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PIPE TRADES WE STAND
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSING SB. SEVEN TWO SIX. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q. THANK
YOU WITH THAT LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ISSUED AS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS-
FRAZIER FONG. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I THANK YOU CENTER I'D
CERTAINLY- DO APPRECIATE HER
TENURE WORK- IN THIS SPACE
ESPECIALLY COMMITMENTS
INVESTING- AND MEDIUM AND HEAVY%
DUTY VEHICLES- I THINK YOU AND
I WERE SITTING NEXT TO EACH
OTHER WHEN WE HAD AN OVERSIGHT
HEARING IN REGARDS TO- THE
STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT- ON
CARBS PROGRAM METRICS AND
EFFECTIVENESS THIS BILL
CERTAINLY DOES DIRECT CARP TO
DO MORE- I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
GET YOUR THOUGHTS IN TERMS OF
DO YOU HAVE. ON THE CONCERNS
THAT YOU MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE ON
AND GIVING BACK GIVING
CARBODIES AUTHORITY- WITH JUST
THE AUDITOR'S REPORT AND IT'S
KIND OF LAPSE IN ITS ABILITY TO
KIND OF- YOU THE DATA AND
MANAGEMENT. OF EXISTING
PROGRAMS. YES THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIR I PROCEED AND YES WE WERE
AT THE SAME HEARING TOGETHER-
AND CERTAINLY YOU KNOW HER THE
SAME INFORMATION ABOUT THIS.
THIS DOESN'T GIVE THEM ANY MORE
AUTHORITY AND THAT THE-
STRATEGY IN THE PLAN THAT WE'RE
PUTTING TOGETHER THEY MAY
CONSIDER AND WE'VE AMENDED THE
LANGUAGES THEY SHALL CONSIDER.
IT'S NOT A REQUIREMENT-
INCLUDING EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
GOALS FOR THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR IT DOESN'T REQUIRE IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE A OR B. TO DO
SO. WE'VE AMENDED IT TO ADDRESS
THAT ANDQUITE HONESTLY WE'VE
AMENDED A LOT OF THE BILL TO
ADDRESS MANY OF THE CONCERNS
WHICH I CAN- EXPLAIN MY CLOTHES
AS WELL SURE. AND THEN IF IS
DOES THE HYDROGEN COALITION IS
STILL IN. THE CHAMBERS. OVER
THERE. CAN I ASK YOU A QUESTION.
SORRY I DON'T WANNA MAKE YOU
RUN ACROSS THE PLATE SHOULD
HAVE ANOTHER MICHAEL VISIT. BUT
IF YOU START ASKING HOUSING- SO
INTO THAT SAID ACTION
COALITION- YEAH THE AUTHOR WAS
IT WAS VERY FIRM AND HER- IN
HER OPENING THAT THIS. BILL
DOES REMAIN TECH NEUTRAL SO.
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE IS HOW IS
YOUR INTERPRETATION. DIFFERENT
OR HOW DO YOU GET TO A
DIFFERENT CONCLUSION. THAT'S A
GOOD QUESTION THANK YOU FOR
ASKING. I BELIEVE THAT THE-
SPONSORS AND THE AUTHORS. I
HAVE TRIED VERY HARD. TO CHANGE
THE VERBIAGE IN THE BILL SUCH
THAT IT IS IN THE SPIRIT OF
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRALITY. BUT
BECAUSE THIS PROGRAM IS THE
PRIMARY PROGRAM FOR FUNDING
HYDROGEN FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THE HEAVY DUTY AND LIGHT
DUTY SPACES IF WE'RE GOING TO
REFOCUS THE PROGRAM TO HEAVY
DUTY. INFRASTRUCTURE WE HAVE TO
ASK THE QUESTION OF WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THE REMAINING
LIGHT DUTY HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. AND IF
THAT ISN'T ADDRESSED IN THIS
BILL TO THE TUNE OF PROVIDING
SUPPORT FOR THAT THOUSAND
STATIONS IN THE FUNDING THAT
GOES ALONG WITH IT HYDROGEN
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE
BASICALLY REMAIN STRANDED AT
TWO HUNDRED STATIONS. OKAY ICE
I CERTAINLY WILL ALLOW THE- THE
OTHERS ONE NOW OR IN YOUR
CLOTHES BUT I CERTAINLY WOULD
JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND IF YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS NOW THANK YOU
MR VICE CHAIR AND ABSOLUTELY
I'D LOVE TO RESPOND TO THAT-
AND THIS IS THE SAME WE WERE
CREATING THE SAME PARTY
LANGUAGE I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
CONFUSION IS BECAUSE WE'D LIKE
TO CLEAR TAT UP THE SAME PARTY
LANGUAGE FOR LIGHT DUTY AS WE
ARE FOR MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY SO
THERE'S NO- YOU KNOW. FOCUSING
MORE ON ON MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY.
AND AGAIN I DO BELIEVE THAT IT
IS TECH NEUTRAL- WE'VE- STATED
THAT VERY CLEARLY IN THE
LANGUAGE- AND IT DOESN'T TOUCH
THE EXISTING 20% CARVE OUT FOR
HYDROGEN FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE
AS IT STANDS- IT ALSO ADDS IN
REFERENCE TO THE STATE'S
HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE GOALS
WHICH IS NOT CURRENTLY IN
EXISTING LAW. THAT'S NOT A
MERRILEES ADDED THAT. SB
SEVENTY SIX ACTUALLY ALSO HAS
THE SUPPORT OF OEMS- SO
ORIGINAL EQUIPMENT
MANUFACTURERS LIKE NICOLA. THAT
MANUFACTURE HYDROGEN VEHICLES
AND HYDROGEN USERS LIKE SOME
LINE. SO WE DO HAVE THAT ARE IN
OUR SUPPORT COALITION AS WELL.
I THINK THAT WAS MY QUESTION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITH QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY SEEING NONE- BUT
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN I THINK YOU
AND THE- COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS
AS WELL AND ALL OF THE GREAT
QUESTIONS THAT WERE PROVIDED I
UNDERSTAND THE OPPOSITION WE'VE
BEEN MEETING WITH THEM AND WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
GETTING TO A GOOD PLACE BUT I
DO BELIEVE THAT THEY SHOULDN'T
BE- WHO THE PICK PICKING
WINNERS AND LOSERS AS ONE OF
MY- SUPPORT- TESTIMONY. A
WITNESSES MENTIONED AND WE WANT
TO ADDRESS EQUITY FIRST YOU
KNOW MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN BURDENED WITH AIR
POLLUTION AND WITH GHG AND
THEY'VE BEEN WAITING FOR US TO
ACT SO BY. SAYING THAT THE
EQUITY FIRST AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES FIRST I THINK IS
THE SPIRIT OF THIS- AND LEAVING
THE TECHNOLOGY TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO THAT ACCORDINGLY- SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I WILL BUT I'M
CERTAINLY OPEN FOR. ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSIONS WITH OUR OPPOSITION
AND SUPPORT AS WE MOVE FORWARD
THANK YOU THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK WITH
WITH MY COMMITTEE AND ON
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE BEEN DOING WITH ALL OF
THE STAKEHOLDERS BUT MOSTLY I
APPRECIATE THE FOCUS THAT
YOU'RE PUTTING ON AIR QUALITY
ON PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN MOST
IMPACTED. BY POLLUTION FROM THE
SECTOR AND- IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THEY HAVE A
CHAMPION AND THEY HAVE THAT IN
USE SO THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS
GREAT WORK WITH THAT OFFICE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY. WE
HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN HI FONG. NO PHONE NO
BERMAN BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO. WELL OKAY THEN.
SORRY SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX. OKAY
CUNNINGHAM NO DALY. SORRY.
SEVEN SIXTEEN. DAVIES DAVIES
MEL GIBSON. KALRA LEE THREE I
MEDINA. MEDINA NOT VOTING AS
AREA. WHEN NO RIVAS. WARD WARD
I WICKS WICKS I. SIX THREE SIX
THREE WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN. YOU'RE
HERE SO YOU'RE UP. YOU CAN
PROCEED ONE READY SIR AND YOU
HAVE- SB. FIVE FIFTY ONE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- THANK YOU I
PROCEED PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY OKAY GREAT- THE MANAGER
MEMBERS A FIVE FIVE ONE. THE MY
SENATE BILLS HERE BEFORE YOU
TODAY AT FIRST I WANT TO JUST
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS- FROM THE
COMMITTEE NOTED ON THE BOTTOM
OF PAGE FOR THE ANALYSIS THESE
REFLECT BOTH COMMITMENTS I MADE
LAST WEEK IN ASSEMBLY
ACCOUNTABILITY TO MINISTRY TO
REVIEW TO ENSURE THE BILL IS
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL AND THAT.
THE HYDROGEN REFUELLING GOALS
WERE ALSO INCLUDED ALONGSIDE
YOUR MISSION- ELECTRIC
ELECTRIFICATION GOALS- FAMILIES
WOULD REMOVE THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION- FROM
THE HYDROGEN CAN HYDROGEN
COMMUNITY AND THEN THE IMMENSE
ALSO MEET THIS COMMITTEES
EXPECTATION THAT THE SEVENTH
ALREADY WORKED. WITH THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY WHEN REPORTING ITS
PROGRESS ON INDUSTRY AND JOB
GROWTH IN THIS SECTOR SO IN
SHORT THIS THIS BILL NOW WOULD
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA ZERO
EMISSIONS VEHICLE AUTHORITY
WITHIN GO BIZ. BUT AS A
INDEPENDENT OPERATING BODY WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY TO THIS
LEGISLATURE- WITH EXECUTIVE
LEADERSHIP AND WITH CLEAR GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES THAT WE CAN HOLD
THE- NOT JUST THIS
ADMINISTRATION BUT OUR OUR
OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE TO AND
KNOW WHERE WE STAND IN TERMS OF
REACHING OUR AGGRESSIVE
TRANSPORTATION GOALS. MEMBERS
WE ARE LIVING IN IT CONTROL THE
M. STATE EVEN THOUGH WE ARE
ALSO THE HOME OF. THE CLEAN CAR
CAPITAL OF THE WORLD OUR
LARGEST EXPORT- WERE LIT WITH
ELECTRIC VEHICLES LAST YEAR-
BUT WE ARE ALSO THE LARGEST
CONSUMER OF PETROLEUM ON THE
ENTIRE PLANET SO WE ARE BOTH
THE HOME OF PROGRESS. IN THE
PLACE WHERE MOST PROGRESS NEEDS
TO BE MADE AND I BELIEVE
THERE'S EVER THIRTY THAT THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD ESTABLISH
WOULD. PUT OUT A MARKET SIGNAL
AND SAY THEY WERE SERIOUS WHEN
WE COME STORES OF POLICY ABOUT
JOB CREATION NOT JUST-
CONSUMPTION SO THIS IS ABOUT
ATTRACTING. INVESTMENT ALL THE
WAY UP STREAM- ALL THE WAY UP
THE VALUE SUPPLY CHAIN INTO
THINGS LIKE LITHIUM PRODUCTION
AND MANUFACTURING- DOWN. TO
DESERVE INFRASTRUCTURE ITSELF-
THE CHOI A FUEL AS WELL AS- AND
USES. SO HOPEFULLY- WE CAN
START TO CHIP AWAY AND HAVE A
ONE STOP SHOP IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE GOVERNMENT SAYS WHEN IT
COMES IS YOUR MISSION VEHICLES
CALIFORNIA IS VERY MUCH OPEN
FOR BUSINESS- WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY REMOTELY OR MATT
PETERSON THE PRESIDENT CEO VLE
CLEANTECH INCUBATORS WELL AS-
MICHAEL COLE THEN HE'S THE
DIRECTOR OF REGULATORY LETTER
FARES IT- THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND. WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR OPERATOR CAN WE
PLEASE HAVE MISTER PETERSON.
TWO MINUTES PLEASE. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU GO
RIGHT AHEAD. THANK YOU. GOOD TO
BE WITH ME THANK YOU- FOR YOUR
TIME THIS AFTERNOON. MISTER
CHAIRMAN IT SET UP- GOOD TO BE
BACK WITH YOU AND- JUST WANTED
TO SPEND A COUPLE MINUTES
SPEAKING TO THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS BILL- WE- INTRODUCED THE
BELL- I WAS THE OUTCOME OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION WHAT TRADITION
PARTNERSHIP WHICH WE FORMED.
WITH THE MAYOR OF THE COUNTY-
SO THE CALIFORNIA EDISON DEPART
WATER POWER CENTRO- AND AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. ALONG WITH OUR
PRIVATE SECTOR PARTNERS AND
LABOR PARTNERS TO SET GOALS TO
ACCELERATE PROGRESS TOWARDS-
TRANSPORTATION EDUCATION IN
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT WHEN THE
OLYMPICS COME TO LOS ANGELES
AND- SO WE SET A NUMBER OF
TARGETS IN AS WE DID THE WORK
TO SEE HOW WE CAN LEADERS
ORIGINALLY RECOGNIZED THE NEED
AND OPPORTUNITY. TO FIND
SOLUTIONS- AT THE STATE LEVEL
AS WELL. AND REALLY OUT OF THE
THINKING AND- HARD WORK THAT
THE TEAM EVERYBODY DID- PUT
FORTH THIS IDEA. OR WHAT IS NOW
THESE ARE MISSIONS- VEHICLE
AUTHORITY AT THE STATE. TO
REALLY SEE HOW WE CAN TAKE A
WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT APPROACH-
TO MEETING OUR STATE SCHOOLS
THAT SET FORTH MOST RECENTLY IN
THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER-
AND REALLY AS WE MOVE TOWARDS
GOING FROM- A MODEST LEVEL OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES BEING SOLD
COMPARED TO A 100% ALL CARS TO
BE SOLD TO BE ZERO EMISSIONS BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE AND HAVING
ALL THE TRAITS TRUCKS TWENTY A
TO BE ZERO EMISSIONS. BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE REALLY RECOGNIZE
THE NEED FOR A LITTLE
LEADERSHIP AND A COUPLE OF
EVERY AGENCY OF COURSE
ACCOUNTABLE BUT TO FIND WAYS TO
WORK TOGETHER WITH PRIVATE
SECTOR LABOR- LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. UP AND DOWN THE
STATE TO SEE HOW WE CAN MAKE
PROGRESS AND HENCE THE BILL
PARTY THAT TO OUR OUR GOOD
FRIEND AND AUTHOR SENATOR HENRY
STERN'S INTRODUCED IMPORTANT
PARTY TODAY YOUR TILES ALSO
WORK AND FINISH UP PLEASE.
THANK YOU BUT WE'RE JUST
PREACHING YOUR CONSIDERATION-
FIND THAT THIS WILL NOT ONLY
ADDRESS MEETING THE GOALS- BY
BY FINDING FUNDING AND
FINANCING TOOLS BUT ALSO.
REALLY MAKING SURE WE TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE OP ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES AND THEN PREPARE
A WORK FORCE FOR THIS
TRANSITION THAT IS.
UNPRECEDENTED ECONOMIC
TRANSFORMATION AS WELL OKAY
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH OKAY WE
HAVE MICHAEL COLE THEN PLEASE.
YES HI GOOD AFTERNOON- TRIP
CREEP IN THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
IN COURT SENATE BILL FIVE FIVE
ONE. FIVE THREE TRUCKS AND
OTHER MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS ARE A HUGE PART OF OUR
TEACHING EMISSIONS AND AIR
POLLUTION. THE VEHICLE TO NOT
OPERATE UNIFORMLY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE BUT RATHER THEY'RE
CONCENTRATED ALONG THE HIGHWAYS
AND- WE KEEP THOSE. MOBILE
SOURCES- THOUGHTFUL FUEL FOR
POWER THAT AND- ARE THE LARGEST
CONTRBUTOR TO THE FORMATION OF
THOSE ON GHG EMISSIONS AND FINE
PARTICULATE MATTER AND TOXIC
MUSEL. PARTICULAR MATTER IN
CALIFORNIA. MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY.
MAKE UP A SMALL SIGNIFICANT
BECOME EXCUSE ME THINK OF A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
HARMFUL AIR POLLUTION IN
CALIFORNIA DESPITE THIS MAKING
UP 7% OF THE VEHICLES ON THE
ROAD. CALIFORNIA HAS THE UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMBINE TWO OF
ITS PRESSING ISSUES DURING THE-
TIME TO LOOK AT PROGRAMS THAT
WILL NEED. YOU TO GO TYPE OF
PRETTY PINK HAIR AND KIND OF
POLLUTION. LIKELY WE HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY TO CONVERT THESE
DIRTY VEHICLES TOOK PORTABLE
AND COST EFFECTIVE CARE MISSION
OPTIONS. GETTING THE VEHICLES
ON THE ROAD WILL TAKE A SUITE
OF POLICIES FROM INSURING THE
VEHICLES ARE AVAILABLE THE
DETERMINATION THE FEELING
AVAILABILITY SUCH AS CHARTERS
AND OTHER OPTIONS. YOU'LL RATE
THAT WILL KEEP THE TOTAL COST
OF OWNERSHIP LOW. THE AUTHORITY
ENVISIONED IN SENATE BILL FIVE
FIVE ONE CAN BE THE QUARTERBACK
FOR ALL OF THESE POLICIES. I
PREVIOUSLY SPOKE TO THIS CAN BE
ABOUT THE CRITICAL NEED TO
CREATE FINANCING OPPORTUNITIES
TO LEVERAGE PRIVATE CAPITAL TO
HELP EMPLOYEES ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. THE CREATION OF THE
AUTHORITY ENVISIONED IN SB FIVE
FIVE ONE WILL PLAY A LARGE ROLE
IN COORDINATING THE STACKING OF
DIFFERENT FUNDS ON TOP OF EACH
OTHER. THE GOAL TO GET THE
LARGEST THING FOR THE PUBLIC
BALKED POSSIBLE. THE AUTHORITY
INVENTION IN FIVE FIVE ONE WILL
ALSO GET LOCAL AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ACTIVITIES
COORDINATED WITH ALL OF THE
GREAT STATE LEVEL EFFORTS BUT
BOBBY HAS BEEN AWAY. THE LEVEL
OF COORDINATION WILL BE
CRITICAL TO HELP GET THINGS AND
STOCK WE KNOW THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
ABOUT WHAT THAT WE DO KNOW THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GET SOMEONE TO
HELP GET THINGS GOING AND THE
AUTHORITY IS A GREAT PLACE TO
HAVE THAT CENTRALIZED ACTIVITY.
YOUR TIME IS UP INCLUDING I'D
LIKE TO THANK SENT. OKAY OKAY
INCLUDING ELECTED THANK SENATOR
STARTING FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND
ENCOURAGING I THOUGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
NOW I HAVE TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SERAPHIN SEVEN
NELSON FROM A CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN BUSINESS COUNCIL AND
TERESA COOK AND I BELIEVE. THAT
MISFITS SOME ENOUGH NELSON IS
HERE AND QUEUED UP. TWO MINUTES
PLEASE HI. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SERAPHIN
SIMON NELSON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN BUSINESS COUNCIL WE
ARE HERE TODAY- WE DID HAVE
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMEND ON SP
FIVE FIVE ONE I WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE THAT THE AUTHOR HAS BEEN
GREAT WITH WORKING WITH OUR
COALITION ABOUT SOME AMENDMENTS
TO THIS BILL- SPECIFICALLY WE
WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE OPPOSITION
FOR THE REASONS THAT. THE
PARITY LANGUAGE HAS BEEN
IMPROVED SO WHERE THERE WAS
ELECTRIC VEHICLE IT NOW SAYS
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE AND THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE FEEL VERY
STRONGLY IS INCLUSIVE OF
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ADDITIONALLY- THE
MOMENT ACTUALLY HAVE NOT SEEN
THEM THE MOST RECENT- BUT IF
AGREED TO WITH WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT WITH CENTER
STERN'S OFFICE- THE AMENDMENTS
INCLUDING FUNDING FOR HYDROGEN
REFUELING AS WELL AS- ELECTRIC
VEHICLE SUPPLY EQUIPMENT
DEVELOPMENT. BEING INCLUSIVE OF
DEVELOPMENT AND TRAINING
INCLUSIVE OF HYDROGEN
REFUELLING AND THEN IN ORDER TO
IMPLEMENT THE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE MARKET DEVELOPMENT
STRATEGY ALL WORKGROUPS- WHO TO
COME TOGETHER TO WORK ON THOSE
EFFORTS WOULD BE INCLUSIVE OF
HYDROGEN REFUELLING- SO AGAIN I
HAVE YET TO SEE THESE
AMENDMENTS- IN PRINT BUT I AM
CONFIDENT THAT WORKING WITH
SENATOR STERN'S OFFICE AND LOST
COMMITTEE AND THIS COMMITTEE-
THAT THOSE CHANGES HAVE BEEN
MADE SO BECAUSE OF THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE. OUR
OPPOSITION AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE FIVE ONE WE WANT
LIKE TO THANK ALL OF THOSE
INVOLVED WITH THIS BILL IN
GETTING TO A HYDROGEN OR SORRY
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL BILL- THAT
WILL HELP CALIFORNIA REACH ITS
GOALS FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
AND TWENTY FORTY FIVE
RESPECTIVELY- THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND- THE REQUESTED BY THE-
THANK YOU AND TERESA COOK. IS
NEXT. THANK YOU CHAIR THERESA
COOK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN COALITION I
WOULD ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH
THE TESTIMONY BEFORE ME THANK
YOU. WE LOVE BRIEF WITNESSES
THANK YOU- LET'S PLEASE GO TO
THE PHONE LINES WERE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF SB.
FIVE FIFTY ONE. OKAY AND AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. ONE ZERO. OUR FIRST WILL
COME FROM WIND THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
KATHY ONCE REPRESENTING PLUG IN
AMERICA CONSUMER ADVOCACY GROUP
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT IN LINE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
TYLER TRITON ON BEHALF OF AN L.
NORTH AMERICA AND OR OR. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
NATALIE NAP ON BEHALF OF THE
REASON SUPPORT. NEXT IS LINE
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
AT THE REPAIR SHOP HALF OF THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES ADOPTED ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO AND THE
OPERATIVE NEAR LONDON STREET IN
THE PARK THANK YOU. NEXT WE GO
TO LINE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS IDEOLOGICAL
AND FROM JOBS IS AMERICA AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT
IS LINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
SHOCKING ON BEHALF OF THREE
FIFTY TELECOM ALLEY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION APPOINTED
PEOPLE AND THE U. S. P.
THREATENING- INSTITUTE. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BUSINESS
PRESS CON RIVERS AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT IS MINE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CATHY SCHAEFER SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND OUR
FINAL IN Q. IS LINE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS JANET
COXED FOUR THREE FIFTY CHOKING
BALLY AND THE ELDERS CLIMATE
ACTION BOTH NORDSTROM YOU
CALIFORNIA AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OPERATOR IS THAT
OUR LAST CALLER. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. THANK YOU LET'S
GO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. ANYONE WHEN
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
YOUR YEARS OF WORK ON CLIMATE
ISSUES AND FOR WORKING TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR TRANSPORTATION
SAID OF- GOALS ARE COORDINATED
AND UNDER ONE ROOF I THINK
THAT'S VERY VERY IMPORTANT AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR TAKING ON
THIS YOU KNOW KIND OF BIG TASK
HERE AND IT SEEMS LIKE YOU'RE
VERY CLOSE TO THE FINISH LINE
WITH IT I KNOW THAT YOU'VE
TAKEN AMENDMENTS AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ADMINISTRATIVE
REVIEW. ABOUT STAKEHOLDERS AS
YOU'VE HEARD OF EXPRESSED SOME
CONCERNS WHICH I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE ADDRESSING ARE YOU
AGREED. TO TAKE THESE
AMENDMENTS AND JUST TO READ
JUST TO RESTATE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THIS COMMITTEE IS
EXPECTING YOU TO TAKE A
REFERENCE TO CHARGING SHOULD
ALSO BE INCLUSIVE OF FUELING AS
IT RELATES TO HYDROGEN
REFERECES INFRASTRUCTURE GOAL
SHOULD BALANCE SCHOOLS IN THE
CHARGING AND REFUELING SPACE AS
IT RELATES TO THE REPORT IF
GROUP IS BEING ASKED TO SHARE
INFORMATION ABOUT JOB TRAINING
AND CREATION IT WOULD BE GOOD
TO IDENTIFY THE LABOR AGENCY OR
SOME OTHER ENTITY TO BE THEIR
PARTNER SINCE ITS INFORMATION
MAY NOT BE AVAIL IT SO EASILY
AVAILABLE TO GO BIZ- AGAIN I
THINK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME IN THE
COMMITTEE. AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- AND YOU
SUMMARIZE THE AMENDMENTS
PERFECTLY AND I'M HAPPY BEGIN
TO ACCEPT THEM AND APPRECIATE
ALL THE ENGAGEMENT FROM MEMBERS
EVEN FORMER OPPOSITION AND- OUR
WHOLE SUPPORT NETWORK HOPEFULLY
WE CAN GET THIS THROUGH AND
START MOVING THE NEEDLE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE GOT A WE GOT A
LOT OF A LOT OF MISSIONS TO
CLEAN UP IN A LOT OF CARS AND
TRUCKS AND BUSES TO MOVE SO.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU CAN WE HAVE A ROLL CALL
PLEASE. THE MOVE. IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
FRIEDMAN. HI FRIEDMAN IPHONE.
FONG NOT VOTING BERMAN. BERMAN
I CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I DALY
DALY AYE DAVIES. DAVIES NOT
VOTING KALRA I'M SORRY GIPSON.
KALRA KALRA I LEE THREE I
MEDINA. MEDINA I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN I WENT. WHEN NOT
VOTING RIVAS. WARD WARD I WICKS
WICKS HI. FOR THANK YOU WHAT IS
THE BOOK TEN ONE TEN ONE WE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS- NEXT MR STERN
YOU HAVE US SENATE BILL SEVEN
NINETY WHICH I'M VERY HAPPY TO
SEE FRONT OF US. THANK YOU
MANAGER THIS IS I WOULD SUBMIT
THE WHILE THIS BILL YOU WILL
HEAR. AT THIS SESSION- SB SEVEN
NINETY. IT'S BOTH THE WILDLIFE
BILL AND A TRANSPORTATION BILL
BECAUSE- FOR THE FIRST TIME
GOING TO INTEGRATE THE EFFORTS
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE AND CALTRANS
WHEN IT COMES TO DEVELOPING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE STATE SO
THAT. WHEN WE'RE ADVANCING NEW
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS WERE
ALSO LOOKING AT. THE WILDLIFE
THAT WE'RE CUTTING OFF AND WHAT
KIND OF CONNECTIVITY WE EXPECT
TO SEE IN THE FUTURE. SO GIVE
DFW DEPARTMENT FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND DOT DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION THE ABILITY TO
WORK TOGETHER AND ACTUALLY
OFFER A NEW COMPENSATORY
MITIGATION CREDIT TO HOPEFULLY
FINANCED SOME OF THE
CONNECTIVITY WERE HOPING FOR
BEFORE THESE PROJECTS ACTUALLY
GET BUILT. AND ENVIRONMENTAL
DAMAGE OCCURS MEMBERS DEPENDING
ON WHERE YOU LIVE IN CALIFORNIA
YOU'RE GOING TO BE GOING
THROUGH SOME MASS EXTINCTION
EVENT IN YOUR OWN NATIVE
ECOLOGY WHETHER IT'S- TROUT OR
SALMON OR- MOUNTAIN LIONS OR-
OR- FLORA AND FAUNA- SO YOU
KNOW IN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE AN ENDANGERED. APEX
PREDATOR THAT IS ON THE BRINK
AND HAS BEEN THE CAUSE OF MANY
DANGEROUS COLLISIONS AND DEATHS
ON THE ROAD- AND WILDLIFE
VEHICLE COLLISIONS ALONE FOR
YOUR PURPOSES TODAY AND
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE SHOULD
NOTE- THAT'S THREE HUNDRED
INSTANCES A YEAR OF INJURY FIVE
ESTIMATED DEATHS AND ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION IN
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL COSTS
ANNUALLY- AND EVEN JUST ONE
ADEQUATE CROSSING STRUCTURE OF
SOME SORT. CAN MAKE ALL THE
DIFFERENCE SO WE'RE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS LEGISLATION
WE'RE ALSO EXCITED ABOUT SOME
OF THE ELEMENTS IN THE BUDGET
THAT. TRY TO INTEGRATE
BIODIVERSITY IS A CRITICAL PART
OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE STRATEGY
AND I THINK WE CAN MAKE BIG
PROGRESS THIS YEAR SO WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND NOTE THAT- OUR SPONSORS
THE- MAN MOUNTAINS RECREATION
AND CONSERVATION AUTHORITY READ
ADDIS I THINK IS ON THE LINE AS
WELL AS BETH PRATT WITH THE
NATIONAL WILDLIFE FEDERATION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND I
HAVE READ ADDRESS AS BEING ONE
OF THE LEAD WITNESSES MR ADDIS
YOU MAY PERCEIVE ONE READY TO
MINUTES. THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS READ OUT OF SOMEBODY UP
IN MID PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT AND SALAS STRONG
SUPPORT HERE TODAY. WE ARE IN
THE MIX ON THIS ISSUE IN OUR
REGION. BOTH BECAUSE WE HAVE
PROTECTED SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
ACRES AND OPERATE TWENTY SIX
OPEN SPACE PRESERVES. WHERE WE
HAVE WILDLIFE AND PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUES ALL THE TIME THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH. UNFORTUNATELY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOESN'T
HAVE A TOOL THAT WE CAN USE IT
ANYTIME ANYWHERE IN THE STATE.
TO ALLOW AN INCENTIVE FOR
CALTRANS AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE OURS. WE HAVE A CRITICAL
PROJECT OURSELVES ON HIGHWAY
SEVENTEEN THAT WERE WORKING ON.
TO TRY TO CREATE BETTER
CONNECTIVITY. UNDER HIGHWAY
SEVENTEEN. AND JUST THIS LAST
APRIL WE DID LOSE ABOUT LINE AT
THAT VERY VERY OR- OUR HOPE IS
THAT. THE THIS BILL PASSES IT
PROVIDES THE TOOL TO
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OURS AND
MANY OTHERS. TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THAT INCENTIVE TO
CALTRANS ALLOW CALTRANS TO
HAPPILY PARTICIPATE THE IN
THESE PROJECTS. AND ULTIMATELY
REDUCE AREAS FOR WILDLIFE AND
IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND I AM ON THE PHONE WE SHOULD
HAVE BETH PRATT FROM THE
NATIONAL WILDLIFE FEDERATION
OPERATOR. HELLO THIS IS BACKING
ME YES. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON
CARE MEMBERS- MY NAME IS BETH
PRATT FOR THE NATIONAL WILDLIFE
FEDERATION I'M REALLY HONORED
TO BE HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETY AND
I REALLY THINK SENATOR HENRY
STERN FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THE
WILDLIFE CORRIDOR ISSUES-
PATIENTS ALL OF YOU'VE SPOKEN
OR SINISTER ANOTHER SPOKE ABOUT
THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS THE
BIODIVERSITY BENEFITS. AND WE
NEED TO DO THAT FOR THOSE
REASONS BUT I'M GOING TO SPEAK
FROM A VERY PERSONAL REASON
BECAUSE YESTERDAY I PICKED A
DYING BOBCAT OFF ONE OF OUR
HIGHWAYS HERE- WHO'S BEEN HIT
BY A CAR. AND WE ACTUAR WILL
GET IN THE RESCUE AND HE'S
FIGHTING BUT I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE WHERE THERE IS A SOLUTION
WE DON'T NEED THIS TO HAPPEN.
AND AS WE KNOW THE AMOUNT LINES
IN THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
ARE ON THEIR WAY OUT THEY ARE
IN BREEDING THEMSELVES OUT OF
EXISTENCE BECAUSE THEY ARE
GETTING HIT BY CARS IN BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T ROAM FREELY SO THIS
IS ONE OF THOSE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROBLEMS WE HAVE A SOLUTION FOR
WE CAN DO IT IT HELPS HUMAN
SAFETY AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
GETS TO THE INCREDIBLE WILD
HERITAGE ANDBIODIVERSITY WE
NEED TO PRESERVE IN THE FACE OF
SOME OF THESE CHALLENGES LIKE
CLIMATE CHANGE. I ENCOURAGE YOU
ALL TO READ THE LA TIMES AND A
REALLY WONDERFULLY WRITTEN
ARTICLE ABOUT THE WILDLIFE
CROSSING AT LIBERTY CANNON
WHICH IS CLOSE QUICKLY BECOMING
A REALITY AND I THINK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THAT AND
IT REALLY TAKES A DEEP DIVE
INTO WHY THESE ARE IMPORTANT
BUT MOST OF ALL JUST HONOR THAT
BOBCAT AND SO MANY OTHERS LIKE
HIM WHO DON'T WIN AGAINST THESE
CARS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. I ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE
YES. THANK YOU MISS PRATT THAT
WAS REAL REALLY POWER. AND
COMPELLING STATEMENT I
APPRECIATED VERY MUCH. WE HAVE
NO OPPOSITION ON FILE. I'M
GOING TO ASK THE OPERATOR WAS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY. NO ONE OF
THE REMOTE LOCATION GO ON A
LIMB AND SAY- COULD WE PLEASE
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
TESTIMONY ON SB. SEVEN NINETY.
OKAY AND AS A REMINDER PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
OPPOSE OR SUPPORT. OUR FIRST
WILL COME FROM LINE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON- BOB ADAMS
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TO THE
PHYSICAL CHECK WITH CALIFORNIA
ADVENTURES ON BEHALF OF INTER
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN NINETY THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO ONE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS PUSHED BUCKET OFF
ON BEHALF OF THE HUMANE SOCIETY
OF THE UNITED STATES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MARGARET TOP ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI DAVID THEY
BEGIN HOLLYWOOD SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION- THIS
BILL CANNOT TAKE EFFECT SOON
ENOUGH WE ARE HONORED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND LASTING
Q. IS ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON OUT OF
THE NEXT BIG HALF OF THE LAND
THAT CAN OCCUR COUNTY NATURE
FOR NATURE FOR ALL NON COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT SO FOR EVERYONE
CITIZENS FOR LOS ANGELES
WILDLIFE DIFFERENT ANIMALS JOHN
AUDUBON ECONOMIC COUNTY PAUL
LANE ACTION NETWORK AND THE.
GREEN A GREEN BELT EIGHT ALL IN
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
IN Q. THANK YOU LET ME TAKE IT
NOW BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ANYONE
ON THE COMMITTEE WELL I WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR FOR IN THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT MEASURE FOR IT
I'M A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL IT REALLY CAN'T COME FAST
ENOUGH WE'VE ALL KNOWN ABOUT
THIS PROBLEM FOR A LONG TIME
AND YOU'VE WORKED ON NOW COMING
UP WITH A CONCRETE WAY OF
FINDING FINDING IN ADDRESSING-
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE- IT DUE
TO TIMING THE COMMITTEE'S GONNA
PROCESS AMENDMENTS AGREED UPON
BY WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE ON
JULY FIRST. WHICH SPECIFY THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
IMPLEMENTING THIS SECTION SHALL
UTILIZE EXISTING PROGRAMS WERE
FEASIBLE THAT'S ON PAGE FOUR OF
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AGAIN I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
WORK OVER THE YEARS ON WILDLIFE
CROSSING ISSUE SO IMPORTANT. DO
WE HAVE A MOTION. WE HAVE A
MOTION. AND A SECOND SUMMER. A
MOTION AND A SECOND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR THEIR SUPPORT AND
MANAGER WOMAN FOR YOUR- YOUR
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS AND IT'S
GOOD TO HAVE A LITTLE WHILE
THIS IN OUR BACKYARDS IT IT MAY
MAKE. PEOPLE REALIZE WHEN YOU
LIVE IN THE SUBURBS AND YOU SEE
A GREAT HAIR AND FIBER HEADER
NO THEM OUTLINES BACK THERE IT
MAKES A LITTLE NERVOUS AT NIGHT
BUT ACTUALLY THINK THAT'S PART
OF BEING HUMAN IS REALIZING
THAT THERE ARE THINGS BIGGER
THAN OURSELVES AND I HOPE THIS.
IS OPENS OUR EYES AND HOLDS ON
TO THE WILDNESS IN CALIFORNIA
WITH THAT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANKYOU VERY MUCH. CAN
WE HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN. HI
FRIEDMAN FIVE FALLS. FONG I
BERMAN BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I DALY. DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON ALL.
GIPSON HI KALRA. KALRA KALRA I
BELIEVE WE AYE MEDINA MEDINA I
NAZARIAN. IN THIS AREA I WENT.
WHEN I READ. WARD FOR I WICKS.
SIX THIRTEEN ZERO THIRTY ZERO
THE BILL'S OUT WILL THE ROLE OF
THANK. WE ARE LOOKING FOR. AND
ASSEMBLY. COMMITTEE. WHOEVER
COMES FIRST WINS. FIRST COME
FIRST SERVED. YEAH LET'S TO ADD
ONS IF YOU WANT TO CALL THE
ROLL ON THE- ON ALL THE BILLS
THEY'LL BE GREAT THANK YOU-
LET'S GO. TO PERISCOPES
STRUCTURE FOR- FILE ITEM OF
FILE ITEM FOR FILE ITEM FOR SB
SIX SEVENTY FOUR CURRENT VOTE
IS NINE TO CUNNINGHAM. SB SIX
SEVENTY FOUR. NOT VOTING IN
THIS AREA. FIRST FOR SIX
SEVENTY FOUR I. RIVAS SO THE
CURRENT VOTE IS TEND TO RIGHT
NOW. TURN OKAY OKAY SO IT WILL
BE TEN THE CURRENT BUT WILL BE
TEN THREE. OKAY YEAH THANK.
FILE ITEM FIVE CURRENT VOTE SIX
THREE. GIPSON. FOR SB SEVEN
TWENTY SIX I APOLOGIZE. NOT
VOTING K. KALRA. KALRA I
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN I. AND RIVAS
HERE SO THE CURRENT VOTE IS
EIGHT THREE. LET'S SEE FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN SB SIX TWENTY
NINE CURRENT VOTE IS ELEVEN ONE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN I RIVAS-
VOTE IS. THIRTEEN ONE. FILE
ITEM FIFTEEN KERN WROTE TEN ONE
GIPSON. SB FIVE FIFTY ONE I
APOLOGIZE FOR. FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN S. B. FIVE FIFTY ONE
GIPSON HI AND THEN READ THIS SO
BE CURRENT VOTE IS. ELEVEN ONE.
HE THAT WOULD BE. FOR CONSENT
ITEMS CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
AYE NAZARIAN THIS AREA AND I
THINK YOU. AND WE DO STILL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS WE WILL BE
RUNNING FOR THE ROLE AGAIN.
YEAH THE BILL PRITCHARD.
THE
SERGEANTS PLEASE CALL SENATORS
ON BERGEN SENATORS MCGUIRE
AGAIN. THANK YOU. I CAN'T HEAR
YOU I'M SORRY. HI.
OKAY WE ARE
STILL WAITING FOR SENATORS
MCGUIRE AND SENATOR ON BURKE
WILL GIVE THEM SEVEN MINUTES.
THEY ARE AFTER SEVEN MINUTES
LASSEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
PRESENT THE BILL'S.
YEAH.
WE
JUST RAN THROUGH IT BUT YEAH WE
CAN DO IT AGAIN A MINUTE LATER
SEE WITH A MISSING A TECHNICAL
AND.
OKAY.
OKAY I'M MISTER
REQUIRES US FOR SOMEBODY TO
PRESENT HIS BILLS MR WARD YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. WE HAVE A MOTION
WE HAVE A SECOND. TECH COOL.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
I'LL BE PRESENTING A SB SIXTY
NINE FOR THE NORTH COAST
RAILROAD AUTHORITY THIS
REORGANIZES THIS- INTO THE
GREAT REDWOOD TRAIL AGENCY
TRANSFERS IS ALREADY RELATED TO
THE RAIL FREIGHT TO THE CINEMA
RAN ERR AREA REAL TRANSIT
DISTRICT ESTABLISHES G. RTA'S
NEW MISSION OF DEVELOPING A
GREAT RIVER TRAIL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT FIRST CAR
BOMB PEARL HARBOR OF CAROL HARD
FROM THE NORTH COAST REDWOOD
AUTHORITY BY PHONE AND ALSO
LARA COHEN. FORMER WESTERN
REGIONAL RAILS TO TRAILS BY
PHONE OPERATOR IF YOU CAN
PLEASE FIND THE WITNESSES. HI
THIS IS CAROL HART CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES PLEASE PROCEED RIGHT.
SURE GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
FRIEDMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN FAVOR
OF SB SIXTY NINE. I'M CAROL
HART A MEMBER OF THE NORTH
COAST RAILROAD AUTHORITY AND
HAVE BEEN WORKING OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS WITH SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND WITH THE STRONG
SUPPORT OF OUR STATE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES. TO TRANSFORM AN
ENTIRELY OBSOLETE AND FULLY
DYSFUNCTIONAL RAILROAD RIGHT OF
WAY AND STATE AGENCY INTO AN
INSPIRATIONAL AND
TRANSFORMATIONAL ECONOMIC
ENGINE AND HUGE RECREATIONAL
DRAW NOT JUT TO THE NORTH
COAST BUT FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIA
AND BEYOND. THE VISION OF THE
GREAT REDWOOD TRAIL IS SIMPLE
TAKE A RIGHT OF WAY THAT WAS
RESERVED FOR A CENTURY. AND
WHAT ALL AGREE HAVE NO HOPE OF
EVER CARRYING RAIL AGAIN
INCREASE THE LONGEST RAIL TRAIL
IN THE COUNTRY AND I CAN SAY AS
SOMEONE WHO IS WORKING THE
PARKS FIELD FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS THAT MUCH OF THE TRAIL
WILL BE CREATED INEXPENSIVELY
AND EFFICIENTLY BY GRADING THE
EXTENT EXISTING RIGHT OF WAY.
AND ADDING A WALKABLE WRITEABLE
THRILLED SERVICE SIMILAR TO
MUCH OF THE FIRST PACIFIC CREST
REVELATION TRAILS IT IS USUALLY
SUPPORTED BY THE CITIES AND
TOWNS FROM SANTA ROSA WILL
EUREKA THROUGH WHICH IT WILL
RUN PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
BUSINESSES TO TI<c.cyan> ANSWERED</c>
HIKERS AND RIDERS FROM AROUND
THE WORLD. THEY MAKE THEIR WAY
FROM SAN FRANCISCO BAY TO
HUMBOLDT BAY- THE- RIVER CANYON
AND THE GREAT BUT REPORTS OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE ARE TO
THRESHOLD HERE AND WITH THE
VISION OF SENATOR MCGUIRE AND
ALL OF YOU AS WELL AS THE
ADMINISTRATION WE CAN FINALLY
SEE THE END OF THIS FUNCTION
AND THE NEEDLESS EXPENSE OF
TRYING TO RESUSCITATE A FAILED
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM BUT
INSTEAD AND BARK ON THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY VISION OF
SUSTAINABILITY BY CREATING. THE
GREAT REDWOOD TRAIL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE
HAVE A COME. BY PHONE. TWO
MINUTES PLEASE. OPERATOR. IT
DOES LOOK LIKE MISS COLLINS
DROP ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
CURRENTLY WE DO NOT HAVE OR
COLON CONNECTED WE DID HAVE
IRVINE AND IT DROPPED OKAY IF
SHE COMES BACK WILL ALLOW HER
TO SPEAK AFTER THE OPPOSITION
DO WE HAVE DAVID JOHN BYRNE
FROM THE TRUMP BRING WRITERS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING THE
OPPOSITION PLEASE. RIGHT HERE-
MADAM CHAIR TWO MINUTES PLEASE-
I'M DAVID SCHOENBERG PRESIDENT
OF THE TRAIN RIDERS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA IS
SPENDING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
RAIL INVESTMENTS ALL OVER THE
STATE. YET ON THE NORTH COAST
CENTER MCGUIRE SEEKS TO HAVE
THE STATE MOVE IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION HE'S ASKING FOR A
STORY TO RAIL BANK THESE ASSETS.
THAT MEANS RIPPING OUT THE
EXISTING TRACKS TO MAKE IT
CHEAPER TO BUILD HIS TRAIL.
WILDTRAK NOTES THE TREMENDOUS
COST OF THE TRAIL
DISPROPORTIONATE TO ITS
TRANSPORTATION BENEFITS WE DO
NOT FUNDAMENTALLY OBJECT TO IT
TRAIL WE DO HOWEVER STRONGLY
OBJECT TO RIPPING OUT THE
RAILS. OUR ORGANIZATION IS
SERIOUS ABOUT GETTING PEOPLE ON
TRAINS. IN ORDER TO REDUCE THE
GHG EMISSIONS FROM
TRANSPORTATION CLIMATE CHANGE
MEANS PEOPLE NEED LOW CARBON
WAYS OF TRAVEL WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT WOULD THROW
AWAY A MAJOR STATE INVESTMENT
IN TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TURN IT INTO
MERE RECREATION. THESE CRACKS
HAVE FUTURE UTILITY FOR LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION IF SB
SIXTY NINE IS APPROVED AND THE
STATE EVENTUALLY DECIDES IT
NEEDS TO RESTORE RAIL
TRANSPORTATION TO THE NORTH
COAST THAT WOULD REQUIRE MOVING
THE TRAIL. IF YOU ALLOW IT TO
BE BUILT WHERE THE TRACKS ARE
NOW THAT WOULD COST MORE THAN
THE SAVINGS THAT THE BILL
ATTEMPTS TO ACHIEVE. MEMBERS
SHOULD KNOW THAT HUMBOLDT
COUNTY HAS BUILT QUITE A SYSTEM
OF TRAILS ALONG SIDE THE REAL
ROAD IT WASN'T A PROBLEM. WE
HAVE NO ISSUES WITH THE RAILS
WITH TRAILS BUT WE VEHEMENTLY
CRITICIZED THE FOOLHARDINESS.
THE STATE NEEDS TO REDUCE GHGS
FOR MOTOR VEHICLES YOU JUST HAD
TO BILLS ON CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION WE RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- OPERATOR
DO WE HAVE LARA CALLING BACK.
WE DO HAVE A MISSED CALL ON
ONLINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
LAURA CULLEN WHICH RAILS TO
TRAILS CONSERVANCY HI I WANTED
TO EXPRESS ARGUES AFFECTS THE
PORT SB SIXTY NINE INTEREST IN
THEIR REQUIRED JETER SHIPPED.
IN CARRYING OUT THE VISION TO
TRANSFORM THIS DORMANT BUT
HIGHLY VALUABLE STATE ASSETS
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILES
OF RAIL CORRIDOR. INTO A WORLD
CLASS RAIL TRAIL THAT WILL
PROVIDE ENORMOUS BENEFITS TO
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AS
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION AS
RECREATION AND AS WITH ENGINE
FOR LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
THE GREAT REDWOOD TRAIL WILL
BECOME PART OF THE NATIONAL
RAIL TRAIL NETWORK AND WILL BE
WHEN COMPLETE THE LONGEST RAIL
TRAIL IN THE COUNTRY AND- ONE
OF THE MOST SPECTACULAR. AND
SCENIC. RAILS TO TRAILS. WORK
HUD OF CAN ACROSS THE COUNTRY-
TO HELP CREATE TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED RAIL TRAILS TOTALING
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND MILES OF
RAIL TRAILS AND WE'RE
PARTICULARLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
ONE BECAUSE WE THINK IT WILL BE
ONE OF THE- MOST VISITED- IN
THE COUNTRY. PASSAGE OF THIS
BILL WILL ENABLE THE STATE TO
TAKE THE NEXT IMPORTANT STEPS
IN DEVELOPING THIS PROJECT
INCLUDING THE PREPARATION OF A
MASTER PLAN AND ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTS. WE INCREASE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM FOR OR
AGAINST I SEE NONE DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
LOCATION I SAYING NO- OPERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
FAVOR OR OPPOSED TO SB SIXTY
NINE. OKAY AND AS A REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONE
ZERO. OUR FIRST WILL COME FROM
LINE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON NATALIE
NATIONALLY HAWK OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IS IN
SUPPORT. AND WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE THAT'S JUST QUEUING UP NOW
JUST BE A MOMENT. THE ONLY
OTHER THAT WE HAVE BEEN Q.
COMES FROM NINE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
TURN MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER
FROM NIELSEN WORKS ON BEHALF OF
MARIN COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NOW
WILL GO BACK TO THE COMMUNITY.
YES OPERATORS OR ANYONE ELSE.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q. THANK
YOU THEY WILL GO BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF ANY
COMMENTS. THANK YOU I. DO SHARE
THE CONCERNS ABOUT REPLACING
RAIL WITH TRAILS HOWEVER IN
THIS CASE. THIS IS A REAL LINE
THAT IS FINANCIALLY INFEASIBLE
AT THIS POINT AND VERY
DISINTEGRATED AND THIS WOULD
LEAST GET SOME PUBLIC BENEFIT
IN USE OUT OF THE- RAIL LINE'S
ALWAYS SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
HER MISTER MCGUIRE. THANK YOU
MANAGER MEMBERS RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST FOR EITHER. THANK YOU
CAN WE HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN HI FONG. FONG I'M
BERMAN BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I DALY DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON. KALRA
KALRA I LEE THREE NINE MEDINA
MEDINA I NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN I
WENT. WHEN I READ THIS RIVAS I
WARD. WARD I WICKS WICKS I.
FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN THAT BILL
IS OUT WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
TO MISTER AMBER BEFORE WE TAKE
UP OUR LAST BILL FROM MR
MAKOWSKI MISTER AMBER YOU MAY.
START WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- HAVE A
MOTION. WE HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT SOME YOU MAY PROCEED-
WELL I I'M GONNA QUIT WHILE I'M
AHEAD SO MADAM CHAIR IS A GOOD
BILL DOES A COUPLE THINGS ONE
IT IT RENEWS THE EXTENDS THE A
TASK FORCE WITH RESPECT TO AUTO
DISMANTLE THERE'S IT HAS A
SPECIAL EMPHASIS IN TERMS OF
REPORTS ON CATALYTIC CONVERTER.
THEFT AND ALSO INCREASES THE-
TOOL WITH WHICH IT CAN BE
ENFORCED SO THAT THE BAD ACTORS
LEAVE THE BUSINESS S. REVIVAL.
YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT GAVIN
MCCUE. AND SEAN BOTHWELL BOTH
BY PHONE IF THE OPERATOR COULD
PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
FOR TO SUPPORT BY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT TWO MINUTES APIECE
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS GAVIN THE QUEUE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AUTOMOBILE
DISMANTLES ASSOCIATION WE ARE
SUPPORTED SENATE BILL THREE
SIXTY SIX. OF THE BILL HELP
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE
REGULATED AND COMPLY WITH THE
LAW WHILE ALSO IMPROVING
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION OF
PUBLIC HEALTH FOR COMMUNITIES.
THAT ARE BEING IMPACTED BY THE
UNSAFE PRACTICES OF UNLICENSED
THIS MAILERS WITH THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. WELL DONE OKAY
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. ABOUT.
TWELVE THE- OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
OUR SECOND. I APOLOGIZE WHAT
WAS THE NAME SHAUN BOTHWELL. SB.
THREE SIXTY SIX. I DO NOT SHOW
OF SEAN ON AT THIS TIME OKAY
THAT'S ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE ON
NOW TO WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
ACTUALLY WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION
ON FILE SO IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE WAR ROOM WITH. I'M
INTERESTED IN TESTIFYING. YES
MY NAME IS KATHERINE
BRANDENBURG REPRESENT ON BEHALF
OF SA RECYCLING AND SUPPORTED
BILL. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM WE HAVE KNOWN AT THE
REMOTE WITNESSES OF LOCATION
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES FOR TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF SB.
THREE SIXTY SIX. AND AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. OUR FIRST WILL COME FROM
LINE THE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JOHN MOFFETT I'M TO HAVE THE
ALLIANCE FOR AUTOMOTIVE
INNOVATON IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT OVER THE LINE NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JENNIFER ROWE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. AND WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE WOULD JUST BE A MOMENT
WHILE WE GIVE THEM THEIR LINE
NUMBER. AND OUR LASTING Q. IT
LINE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MELISSA HI DO
ON BEHALF OF HONDA IN SUPPORT
THANKS SO MUCH. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I THINK WE HAVE A COUPLE
OF MOTIONS AND SECONDS ALREADY-
IS THERE ANYONE WISHING TO MAKE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. WELL
I JUST WANT TO FIRST COMMAND
THE DMV IN THE VEHICLE
DISMANTLING INDUSTRY STRIKE
TEAM FOR THE WORK THAT THEY'VE
DONE SINCE THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE TASK FORCE- THIS IS A BIG
PROBLEM AND IT'S GROWING I JUST
SPENT ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS ON MY PREVIOUS. BY TWO
THOUSAND TEN PREVIOUS PUTTING A
CATALYTIC CONVERTER CAGE OVER
WHICH NOW RATTLES LIKE CRAZY-
BUT AT LEAST TO GIVE ME SOME
MEASURE BE ABLE TO SLEEP AT
NIGHT- GIVEN THE SCOURGE OF
CATALYTIC CONVERTER THEFTS SO I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR TAKING
THIS PROBLEM ON IT'S A HUGE
ISSUE FOR A LOT OF OUR
RESIDENTS- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSER. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THING YOU JUST DID. GREAT CAN
WE HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN. HI
FRIEDMAN I FONG. FONG I BERMAN.
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
I DALY DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES I
GIPSON. KALRA KALRA I LEE. LEE
I MEDINA MEDINA I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN I WENT. WHEN I RIVAS
RIVAS I WARD BY WARD I WICKS
WICKS HI FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT AND MR
WARD THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS
REQUIRES LAST BILL SB TWO
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU CENTER
BASKING MADAM CHAIR AND OTHERS
HAVE ANY- PRESENT TO SENEGAL TO
THIRTY ONE AND A HALF SENATE
MCGUIRE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES HAVE BEEN THE
CARETAKERS OF THE GOLDEN STATE
PERCENT TREES PROTECTING
PRECIOUS COASTLINE FOR SOME
WILDLIFE THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION TO TRANSFER THE
BLUES BEACH. ORCHAD BORN GOLD
BEACH PROPERTY MENDOCINE COUNTY
TO A QUALIFIED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZED BY CALIFORNIA TRIED
EXPERTS MAINTAINED TO MAINTAIN
PROTECTION AND PUBLIC ACCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE A
WITNESS AND SUPPORT MELANIE
REFERENDUM- FROM THE SURE WOULD
VALLEY BAND OF POMO INDIANS BY
PHONE I BELIEVE- THIS OPERATOR
IF YOU CAN PLEASE FIND OUR
WITNESS. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE
WITNESSING YOU ON THE CALL
PLEASE- REMOVE YOURSELF FROM
MUTE IF YOU ARE AND- Q. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND I HAVE
A SHOW NO ONE. GO AHEAD WHEN
READY PLUS WHAT. I'M HERE. I
HEARD SAY I HEAR MA'AM ARE YOU
ON THE PHONE ON MUTE. HELLO YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD TWO MINUTES
PLEASE. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS MELANIE RASKIN ENSURE VALLEY
BAND OF POMO INDIANS TRIBAL
CHAIR. AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL PRESENTED BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE. TO TRANSFER THIS LAND
OF WHOSE BEACH OR CHAPLAIN
GULCH TO THE THREE TRIBES AND
NONPROFIT AGENCY THAT WE'RE-
GOING TO BE. ORGANIZING WE ARE
THE BEST AFFORDABLE LAND. TO
PROTECT AND UTILIZE THEIR
NATURAL RESOURCES THAT ARE
THERE FROM THE TRIBES FOR.
KLUTE MEDICINAL PURPOSES. TO
FISH AND PROVIDE TO OUR
FAMILIES- WE PLAN TO KEEP THE
LAND AS IS- IN REGARDS TO THE.
STATE THE STATE. I'M SORRY.
WOOD COUNTY PLAN AS IS WHERE IS
IT WILL BE PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE
BEACH- THERE WILL BE NO
ADDITIONAL DEVELOPMENT. HE AND
WE WOULD LOVE TO GET. I VOTE
FOR THE PROTECTION OF ANY AND
ALL ARCHAEOLOGICAL SITES THAT
COULD BE ON THIS PROPERTY- AND
ONCE ALL THAT HAPPENS. WE WILL
BE ABLE TO- FORWARD AND
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL BE THE
FIRST OF MANY PLANNED TRANSFERS
THAT CAN HAPPEN THROUGH
CALTRANS AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY I DON'T HAVE
ANY REGISTERED OPPOSITION-
OPERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
WELL TO ANYONE IN THE ROOM I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY WISHING TO
TESTIFY THERE'S NO ONE AT THE
REMOTE LOCATION. OPERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO THIRTY
ONE. THANK YOU AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO SB TWO THIRTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE. THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME AGAIN. ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. SH AND WE HAVE NO
ONE COMING UP AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU I'LL TAKE IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANYBODY
HAS COMMENTS AT LEAST. I'LL
JUST SAY THAT IN ORDER TO ARE
PROPERLY HONOR AND PRESERVE THE
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES ON THE-
PROPERTY. I ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR HE'S NOT HERE BUT I DO
ENCOURAGE HIM TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH CALTRANS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CLARIFY THE
DEFINITION OF CULTURAL
RESOURCES. ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AND TO PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY IN THE BILL TO
ALLOW FOR THE PROPERTY TO BE
TRANSFERRED DIRECTLY TO THE
TRIBES RATHER THAN TO A
NONPROFIT I WILL ABSOLUTELY BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY AND I
APPRECIATE HIM BRINGING IT
FORWARD. WITH THAT WE HAVE A
ROLL CALL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
FRIEDMAN. HI FRIEDMAN IPHONE.
FONG AND I BERMAN BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY.
DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON.
KALRA KALRA I LEE. LI HI MEDINA
MEDINA AND NAZARIAN NAZARIAN I
WENT. WHEN I RIVAS RIVAS FIVE
WARD WARD I WICKS WICKS HI
FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO THE
BILL'S OUT I WANT TO THANK
MISTER WARD FOR DOING EXTRA
CREDIT WORK. YOU WILL BE
REWARDED LATER I'M SURE THANK
YOU I KNOW MISTER MCGUIRE
APPRECIATES IT- WE DO HAVE
BILLS THAT ARE- ON CALL CAN WE
TAKE A ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
PLEASE. ITEMS ON CONSENT RIVAS.
RIVAS FILE ITEM FOR SB SIX
SEVENTY FOR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOETEN
THREE- RIVAS RIVAS I FINAL VOTE.
ELEVEN THREE. FILE ITEM FIVE SB
SEVEN TWENTY SIX THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
KERBAL EIGHT THREE. A RIVAS
RIVAS I FINAL VOTE. NINE THREE.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN SB SIXTY NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS GIPSON. OKAY
CURRENT LOTUS STILL FOURTEEN
ZERO. FILE ITEM TWELVE S. B.
TWO THIRTY ONE OF THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
GIPSON. K. FOLLOW OF THE
CURRENT LOTUS STILL FOURTEEN
ZERO. FILE ITEM THIRTEEN SB SIX
TWENTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS HERBAL
IS THIRTEEN ONE. RIVAS RIVAS I
FINAL VOTE FOURTEEN ONE. FILE
ITEM FIFTEEN SB FIVE FIFTY ONE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS RIVAS.
RIVAS I MAKING THE FINAL VOTE
TWELVE ONE. FILE ITEM SIXTEEN
SB SEVEN NINETY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTERS
THIRTEEN ZERO RIVAS RIVAS I
WICKS WIXII FINAL VOTE IS.
FIFTEEN ZERO. FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN SB THREE SIXTY SIX THE
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT LOTUS
FOURTEEN ZERO GIPSON. FOR
VOTERS STILL FOURTEEN ZERO THE
ONLY ONE WE'RE WAITING FOR.
THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK MS
RIVAS FOR SUBBING TODAY VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED- LET'S LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR A FEW MORE
MINUTES FOR MISTER GIBSON. HERE
IT COMES OKAY LET'S CALL THE-
ITEMS THAT IS TO GIVE THE NEEDS
TO VOTE ON. HI OKAY. SURE OF
COURSE THANKS OKAY HE'S ON A
CALL THE ROLL THREE FILE ITEM
ELEVEN SB SIXTY NINE OF THE
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS GRABLE FOURTEEN
ZERO MISTER GIBSON GIBSON I
FINAL VOTE IS FIFTEEN ZERO FILE
ITEM TWELVE- S. B. TWO THIRTY
ONE THE MOTION IS TO FASTER
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT LOTUS
FOURTEEN ZERO GIPSON. FINAL
VOTE FIFTEEN. ZERO FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN ACTUALLY THAT ONE YOU
ARE GOOD ON. A FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN SB FIVE FIFTY ONE THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- I'M SORRY YOU
ARE GOING ON THAT ONE TOO- I
THINK. WE HAVE ONE FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN SB THREE SIXTY SIX OF
THE MOTIONS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS FOR VOTES
FOURTEEN ZERO GIPSON. GIPSON
NINE FIFTY FINAL VOTE FIFTEEN
ZERO AND WE'RE DONE. THANKS FOR
THAT WERE ADJOURNED.